bonjour et bienvenue pour cette première
premier épisode de cette nouvelle série
qui s'appelle probablement où je vais
avoir l'occasion de discuter avec des
gens trop cool et essayer d'aller un
petit peu loin dans la réflexion et de
grands avoir le temps de poser pas mal
de choses et de discuter des choses
diverses et variées comme vous savez je
suis très bas cela pour que très bas
voire du coup ça risque de durer assez
long on va voir combien de temps ça va
durer en tout cas pour cette première
émission j'ai vraiment l'honneur et la
chance d'accueillir christophe michel de
la chaîne
hygiène mentale qui à mon sens c'est
vraiment vraiment le truc que je
recommande en premier pour quelqu'un qui
veut découvrir un peu ce qui se fait de
bien sur youtube
je repense à leur dire allez voir yann
mental après pour aller voir d'autres
monsieur fini tout ça mais quand ces
parisiennes mental nous ça fait très
plaisir de commencer avec toi à
christophe bas merci les bains moi aussi
ça me fait plaisir de couper le cordon
l'inauguration de nouveaux formats et
pour commencer à ce que tu vois un peu
présenter un peu ton parcours qui est
tué
d'où tu viens commentant arrivée à la
haute et aujourd'hui vous présenter mon
parcours je sais pas trop ce que tu
entends par là parcours religieux mon
parcours scolaire
qu'est ce qui t'a amené à arriver
jusqu'à aujourd'hui qu'elles sont aimées
aventures de parcours dans les domaines
que tu fais ce qui te semble pertinent
ben je ne sais pas trop quoi dire ni
comment c'est l'histoire d'une vie c'est
difficile à établir
moi par exemple mon parcours religieux
sur la croyance par exemple j'étais très
croyant quand j'étais petit j'ai été
baptisé j'allais au catéchisme
et puis je crois que arrivée à l'école
il y a eu une sorte de prise de
conscience je me suis rendu compte
probablement dans un cours d'histoire où
j'ai dû poser une question un peu idiote
à base de dinosaures et puis d'arche de
noé la passe de mon prof d'histoire qui
a dû juste sourire et essayé d'esquiver
la question règle dans ses yeux
j'ai compris qu'en fait tous les adultes
n'étaient pas d'accord et qu' il n'y
avait pas consensus comme je l'imaginais
et que apparemment lui il avait une
autre vision que celle que j'allais
à partir de ce moment là où j'ai remis
en question plein de truc particulier la
religion et c'est ça un petit peu qui
m'a lancé dans les sciences parce que je
continue à être croyant mais plutôt une
sorte de déisme a détaché de toute
religion organisée et moi quand je me
suis lancé dans une des études de
sciences c'était pour poursuivre le
divin pour connaître les règles de la
nature pour connaître les lois que dieu
avait posé au début de l'univers de
pourquoi le monde fonctionné comme ça
donc voir mon parcours en au lycée puis
après à l'université j'ai fait un master
de sciences fondamentales la science
physique c'était sûr mécanique quantique
mais les semi conducteurs un petit peu
de baume au relativisme et de relativité
maintenant là dessus et c'était dans une
sorte de quête spirituelle pour
connaître les lois de l'univers quoique
cela me paraissait la meilleure façon de
connaître comment fonctionne le monde
est ce qu'il y à avant ou après plutôt
que de lire les centres écriture est
d'essayer de les interpréter quoi du
coup
petit à petit bain je me suis de plus en
plus des tâches et des croyances
religieuses parce que le sujet de la
science l'astrophysique l'astronomie les
particules la chimie en fait c'est
fascinant en soi puis ça m'a intéressé
en tant que sujet lui-même quoi donc bah
du coup mon parcours scolaire
je viens de te lire c'est plutôt plutôt
scientifique mais ce qui m'a amené à ce
que je fais aujourd'hui c'est pas du
tout ça c'est pas du tout mon parcours
scolaire même au contraire je dirais
c'est presque par opposition à ce
parcours scolaire quand très tard dans
ma vie quand j'avais fini mes études
depuis très longtemps je devais avoir 30
ans je me suis rendu compte que en fait
je me pensais une scientifique parce que
j'avais fait des études de sciences et
que dans une conversation où on doit
faire marcher la méthode scientifique
pour en arriver au vrai
je me suis rendu compte très tard que
personne n'avait jamais appris la
méthode en fait à l'université on
apprenait les résultats de la méthode
scientifique
les formules les conclusions c'est à
dire comme comment marche la gravitation
etc
mais c'était seulement les résultats de
la science
tiab le compte rendu les objets sinon la
méthode elle même qui a permis d'obtenir
ces résultats
jamais un prof n'a pris une heure de son
temps pour me l'expliquer contrairement
par exemple à ceux qui auront fait des
études dans les sciences humaines
moi je connais plein de collègues que
j'en fais d'autres branches que les
miennes en psychologie sociale
sociologie en est où ils ont eu des
cours d'épistémologie par exemple
qu'est-ce que la connaissance qu'est ce
que la méthode scientifique comment
marche cette histoire de revue par les
pairs de comités de lecture de
publications dans des revues
spécialisées moi on ne me l'avait jamais
appris j'ai dû apprendre ça bien plus
tard deux mois même en autodidacte et
c'est face à ce constat là que je me
suis dit mais il ya un problème car ça
devrait être ça l'important a expliqué
d'abord et après une façon de secondaire
les résultats qu'on a obtenus en
utilisant cette méthode quoi et c'est
pour ça que je me suis lancé d'abord
qu'en tant que enseignants et j'ai fait
quelques années de prof de physique et
de maths dans le secondaire et puis
ensuite face à la difficulté du métier
et puis un petit peu j'avais
l'impression de ne pas servir à grand
chose mais je me suis décidée en 2014 de
lancer une chaîne d'éducation populaire
en vidéo pour toucher plus de gens pas
forcément les gens qui vont à la fac pas
forcément les gens qui ont la chance de
pouvoir aller à l'école mais tous ceux
qui ont une connexion internet est passé
ça un petit peu l'origine de mon projet
hygiène mentale
c'était de parler de ces sujets là mais
pas en classe du coup j'ai une première
question c'est une autre question
avec quelques futon déclic est-ce que tu
as l'impression que tu racontes ça va
jusqu'à trente ans tu avais l'impression
de pas trop intéressé à l'épistémologie
et puis tout à coup
qu'est ce qui t'a amené vers
l'épistémologie ben ouais la découverte
petit à petit que je pensais être au
point là dessus que je pensais connaître
la méthode que je savais ce que c'était
l'épistémologie alors qu'en fait quand
je discute avec des gens qui eux savent
vraiment ce que c'est parce qu'ils ont
étudiés qu'ils ont un peu de ses sujets
j'ai dû me ridiculiser une fois ou deux
en fait
pour connaître grand chose n'a pas avoir
lu les bons auteurs pas trop m
intéresser aux sujets on n'allait jamais
appris ça à l'école non plus et puis je
vais en fait c'est face à ce constat là
que je me suis intéressé tout seul parce
que voyant mon ignorance
voilà maintien pour reprendre les termes
que tu utilises je me suis rendu compte
de l'étendue de mon ignorance sur le
sujet et c'est ça qui m'a vexé et par
réactance j'ai voulu approfondir le
sujet mais que ces quelques personnes en
particulier kate a rencontré je sais pas
si tu es parce que si j'en cite quelques
uns ce serait faire oublier tous les
autres qui ont participé le cheminement
mais en particulier j'ai une collègue
qui habite dans ma ville une amie à moi
qui a suivi des études de psychologie
sociale qui elle a fait une thèse
contrairement à moi l on lui a appris à
monter des protocoles carré scientifique
pour calculer des vraisemblances des
valeurs p et puis tiré une
significativité de résultats et c'est en
discutant avec elle à l'observatoire
zététique c'est l'association dans
laquelle je me suis investi à grenoble
pour tester les phénomènes paranormaux
mais radiesthésiste les sourciers les
voyants et c'est quand c'est au moment
de monter un protocole c'est elle qui
m'a tout appris en fait qui m'a dit non
mais c'est pas comme ça qu'il faut faire
pour avoir un résultat significatif il
faut avoir au moins tant d'échantillons
pour que la significativité etc etc
c'est à ce moment là en fait que j'ai
appris sur le tas comment faire de façon
un peu carré un protocole qu'ils
puissent être un peu rigoureux qu'est ce
que c'est qu'un double aveugle comment
le faire parce qu'il ya croire savoir ce
que ça veut dire et puis
l'avoir fait en vrai dans un laboratoire
face à des vrais gens et les deux bas on
se rend compte que c'est très différent
et voilà probablement elle qui m'a le
plus appris sur la méthodologie ok mais
du coup à ce moment là tu étais déjà
dans le milieu fait était à
l'observatoire c est éthique déjà c'est
ça oui bah de fait très longtemps que
moi je me suis investi dans cette
association et pour d'autres raisons
parce que j'avais un intérêt pour les
phénomènes paranormaux qui est qui est
vraiment car rien à voir avec ce que ce
dont on vient de parler jusqu'à là les
sciences l'épistémologie moi je
m'intéressais aux fantômes aux ovnis à
la possibilité de l'existence de la
télépathie ou de la voyance en
particulier dans le village à moi il ya
beaucoup de rebouteux de coupeurs de feu
qui prétend de pouvoir guérir telle ou
telle thérapie ou soulager les blessures
ou les brûlures avec des prières ou avec
des petites as demain et moi c'est en
voulant tester ça de façon peu
scientifique que je me suis investi dans
l'observatoire zététique pour essayer de
monter des protocoles et puis de pouvoir
discuter avec ces gens là et savoir
comment on peut mettre en évidence leurs
dons de la meilleure façon qu'ils
puissent exister la façon la plus
rigoureuse qui puisse exister
puis de la façon en utilisant la méthode
scientifique qui me paraissait être la
plus adéquate pour me tester ces genres
de prétention là tu me paraît encore
aujourd'hui être la plus adéquate mais
pas du coup c'est en essayant de monter
ces protocoles là que j'ai appris
beaucoup sur les statistiques et sur la
méthodologie elle même la super c'est
très intéressant
une question que je me pose souvent
c'est parce que j'ai l'impression qu'en
fait finalement les scientifiques sont
pas forcément si à l'aise avec ces
notions de
des protocoles en tout cas ce fut sur la
notion des statistiques notamment de
cette fameuse paix value donc toi tu dis
qu'après tu as ton master en sciences
physiques que tu étais pas forcément
très à l'aise avec ces notions
moi personnellement après ma thèse je
n'étais pas très à l'aise avec ces
notions un petit peu parce que j'ai
blogué un petit peu dessus mais c'est un
peu par accident que je suis tombé sur
ces notions du coup est ce que tu penses
qu'il ya beaucoup de scientifiques plein
de gens qui ont un doctorat en confiance
on va dire notamment en physique où les
défenses un peu plus dur où il ya moins
ces questions de méthodologie qui se
pose est ce que tu penses que la plupart
sont sensibilisés à ces notions si tu
devais parier un peut qu'être sentiment
par rapport à tout ça je pense que oui
tu as bien établie le problème je pense
que tous ceux qui s'arrêtent avant de
faire une thèse destinés à la recherche
le i l'ont jamais eue comme moi deux
notions de ces genres de sujets là sur
l'épistémologie et puis sur la lépi
value et c'est seulement que ceux qui
font une thèse qui sont donc destinés à
devenir chercheur à qui on apprend
pourquoi l'importance de il faut faire
attention à la significativité à la
puissance de du test à au nombre
d'échantillons donc toutes ces histoires
de statistiques ça s'apprend je pense
pas en thèse et puis même parmi tous
ceux qui ont fait un doctorat
je pense que ceux qui ont fait des
doctorats en sciences humaines sont
beaucoup plus sensibilisés à ces sujets
là parce que c'est vraiment le son de
leur travail et c'est incontournable
alors que quand on manipule des
électrons par exemple ou juste des
masses sur un tapis roulant ou des
objets du monde physique quoi papa dada
des sciences humaines et bien les mêmes
causes donne toujours exactement les
mêmes effets alors je peux leur lâcher
une balle a depuis un mètre cinquante de
hauteur en chronométrant le temps
qu'elle va mettre pour atteindre le sol
les conditions initiales si elles sont
les mêmes
le résultat est toujours le même si pas
du tout le cas quand on pose un
questionnaire face à des gens dans la
tous les gens sont très différents et on
l'a on est obligé de faire des
statistiques pour essayer de dégager des
tendances et de mesurer des toutes
petites tailles des faits dans des
nombre d'échantillons très grand et donc
je pense que comme tu l'as dit ceux qui
sont en doctorant en sciences de la
matière c'est moins crucial pour eux ces
histoires de statistiques ils ont juste
à trouver la loi et puis une fois que la
formule est établi après les
statistiques c'est juste les erreurs de
mesure de nos appareils assez facilement
serre si facile à traiter
alors que les sciences humaines voilà
c'est là où on a vraiment besoin de
statistiques et c'est ça que j'adore à
l'association de l'observatoire
zététique c'est qu'il ya tellement de
profils très différents qui sont
mélangés dans cette association
dès qu'ils ont fait des études des pas
du tout il ya des étudiants des chômeurs
des retraités et ben du coup tout ce ce
panel de parcours fait qu'on peut
s'échanger des trucs et astuces et des
méthodes et des acquis entre nous que
j'aurais jamais trouvé en restant juste
dans un laboratoire de physiciens par
exemple la ccrd truc que j'adore avec
youtube c'est que devant on pète au
contact de gens qui sont très éloignées
de notre domaine d'expertisé et regarder
des biologistes parler de plein de
choses qui ce qui est pas du quotidien
et d'ailleurs c'est aussi ce que
j'espère faire dans ce podcast essayer
d'aller un peu à la rencontre des gens
avec d'autres expertises que la mienne
tu sais qu'il ya des grands laboratoires
qui font attention à placer les machines
à café dans le laboratoire de façon
judicieuse pour que les gens de
différents services puissent communiquer
et quand il ya l'analyste qui croise
juste le technicien il s'échange des
trucs et donc on en apprendre sur les
défauts de la machine et et les infos
elle tourne autour des machines à café
il me semble que youtube
ça devient un petit peu la machine à
café mondial où les gens de différents
services dans l'administration de notre
planète puissent se croiser regarder un
petit peu les problématiques des autres
sans m'inspire et puis ça fait émerger
peut-être un petit peu de sérendipité ce
sera chouette
ouais mais du coup j'ai tendance à
encourager pas mal les gens à
ah et regardez un peu ce qui se fait sur
les chaînes youtube qui sont pas leurs
domaines d'expertisé parce que souvent
on apprends moi j'apprends énormément en
regardant des vidéos d'autres youtube je
vais revenir sur une remarque que tu as
dit et en début de podcasts tu disais
que la tête a quitté l'enseignement
parce que tu te sens des tu te sentais
pas assez utile tu peux développer ce
point non te principalement parce que je
ne sais pas si j'étais un très bon prof
que c'est un métier assez difficile
surtout dans le secondaire ça consiste à
apprendre des choses à des personnes
sont obligées d'être là et bien que si
elle pouvait il serait dehors en train
de prendre le soleil ou de faire autre
chose et quand on est obligé de suivre
un cursus scolaire que l'on y va parce
qu'il ya un appel et que si jamais on
est marqué absent alors il y aura des
sanctions
si c'est ça leur seule motivation ou
d'aller en cours le prof qui doit
expliquer des choses sur la physique où
les statistiques derrière c'est
difficile quoi il y en a il ya des
enseignants qui s'y prennent très bien
car les sortes de vocation je suis très
admiratif moi je ne sais pas si j'avais
vraiment cette vocation la de tenir une
salle faire régner une discipline qui
ont des compétences très différente des
équations de la physique et tu continues
à ce moment là tu t'es dit que ce serait
plus utile 21 ans 1 sur youtube quand ça
s'est passé
non ce ne serait pas passé comme ça une
vie c'est très chaotique il se passe
plein de choses
moi j'ai toujours eu deux passions dans
ma vie depuis tout petit je dessine
d'abord au crayon puis à l'entrée et
puis y ait plein de techniques
traditionnelles et puis ensuite j'ai
découvert l'ordinateur et j'ai commencé
à faire des infographies puis de la 3d
et puis une autre de mes passions c'est
celle que j'ai expliqué tout à l'heure
c'est la poursuite des règles de
l'univers et de la parole divine à
travers les sciences et la physique et
un jour ma mère à un moment où il
fallait probablement choisir une
orientation scolaire m'a bien fait
comprendre que il y a plus de débouchés
en sciences que dans les arts et le
dessin
ce en quoi je la remercie parce que
c'est vrai mais j'ai toujours gardé
cette passion pour le design la 3d
l'infographie et donc en 2014 au moment
de lancer mon projet hygiène mentale
en fait ce que je cherchais c'était un
projet personnel pour pour moi pour un
épanouissement tout à fait personnelle
sans autre but que ça qui puisse réunir
mes deux centres d'intérêts dans le même
projet et c'est pour ça que j'ai décidé
de parler de méthodologie scientifique
appliquée au paranormal en dessin en
faisant des animations donc à ce moment
là ça faisait combien temps qu'elle
était à l'observatoire zététique pour
donner un ordre d'idée je devais faire
huit ans ouais presque dix ans après le
succès que l'on connaît
mais du coup il ya un peu cette fin
j'étais déjà entendu dire que tu n'aimes
pas te qualifier d et éthicien tu peux
expliquer ça ouais tu veux parler du mot
no et éthiques
c'est un très très vieux mots qui
étaient utilisés pendant l'antiquité
pour désigner une sorte de méthode
permettant de découvrir la raison des
choses c'est à dire trier le vrai et le
faux
avant même la méthode scientifique que
l'on utilise depuis quelques siècles
c'était un mot qui est de les utiliser
puis il est tombé dans l'oubli
complètement et plus personne n'a jamais
entendu parler pendant des siècles et
des siècles quoi au moyen-âge quinquin a
ressorti le mot et éthiques
un mathématicien arabe pour désigner une
sorte d'algèbre parce que les
démonstrations permettait de trier
centre les affirmations mathématiques
qui sont vrais et celle qui s'enfonce
une bonne usage du mot et puis ce sera
pas longtemps et puis ce mot est
retombée dans l'oubli pendant très
longtemps plus personne ne l'utilisait
ya seulement au 19e siècle
un anglais qu'il l'a ressorti des
cartons car il voulait faire une sorte
de petite expérience sociologique un peu
troll pour voir ce que les gens
répondrait si jamais on prétend que la
terre était plate
aux gens qui répondent mais non vous
savez la terre elle est ronde
on le sait il répondait à huy balesi
prouver le mois mais avec des choses que
vous vous pouvez trouver en vous
référant en faisant confiance à une
autorité jeu prenant plainte intel a
fait le tour du monde et il m'a dit que
peut-être comment vous avec ce que vous
voyez depuis chez vous vous pouvez nous
démontrer qu'elle est ronde ou plate est
en fait les réponses des gens sont sont
misérables en fait c'est on est très
mauvais a expliqué pourquoi on pense que
la terre est ronde et en grande partie
parce qu'on fait confiance ont fait
confiance aux images de la nasa ont fait
confiance à l'inca en confiance aux
astronautes ont fait confiance à ceux
qui ont fait le tour du monde et soi
même s'il trouvait alors oui l'angle de
la lune le reflet de l'éclipsé des
jeunes bah en fait c'est pas si simple
et donc il avait fondé la lah esthétique
society la société et éthiques et c'est
un mouvement qui a perduré dans le temps
puis qui sait mêler un petit peu avec
des zozos qui pense vraiment que la
terre est plate pour de vrai aujourd'hui
il ya toujours ce moment dans le monde
anglophone
il est toujours utilisé pour désigner
les partisans de la terre plate pour pas
essayer de chercher le mot zététique
dans le monde anglophone
vous découvrirez des sites qui nous a
absolument rien à voir avec ce que l'on
trouve dans le monde francophone et un
bon bain à cause de toute cette histoire
tumultueuse blasetti car alain sens
moderne qui est très différente ce qui
rend les dictionnaires
c'est difficile de s'en réclamer
aujourd'hui en france c'est un henry
broc qu'il avait remis au goût du jour
dans les années 80 parce qu'il trouvait
que scepticisme avait une connotation
négative en français quand quelqu'un est
sceptique
on pense de lui tout de suite a priori
que c'est quelqu'un qui refuse de
changer d'avis même quand on lui met des
preuves souvenez qu'il a tort c'est
comme ça quelqu'un de sceptiques et
alors c'est pas du tout comme ça que le
scepticisme de l'antiquité grecque et à
entendre
c'est pas du tout comme ça que moi je
l'entends quand moi je dis que moi je
suis sceptique ça veut dire même en fait
exactement le contraire être sceptique
ça veut dire avoir l'audace de remettre
en question les choses pour lesquelles
on n'a pas assez de preuves petit 1 et
petit dos
avoir l'audace de changer d'avis et de
se mettre à croire si jamais il y a
suffisamment de preuves et donc mettre
comme ça en propre de façon
proportionnelle les preuves et les
croyances ce qu'on appelle le
rationalisme donc moi je dis que je suis
rationaliste je dis que je suis un
sceptique
mon association elle s'appelle
l'observatoire zététique parce que c'est
son nom historique et éthicien ça me
paraît un peu bizarre comme vous et moi
dans ma vie j'aime bien essayer d'être
prudent mais jamais je dis que je suis
un prudent titien moi dans ma vie
j'aimerais pouvoir faire en sorte d'être
généreux mais jamais ça viendra l'idée
de dire que je suis un généticien dans
ma vie j'essaye de mettre en
correspondance
mes croyances avec l'épreuve mais je
vais pas dire pour cela que je suis et
éthicien une autre est question avec m
j'aimerais te poser c'est si tu pouvais
revenir en arrière et parler à ton mois
du passé lyon tout moi je sais qui fait
des études en sciences physiques par
exemple quelqu un qu est ce que tu
dirais qu est ce que tu as appris qu est
ce que tu aimerais lui avoir dit lui
dire donc j'aimerais lui ai expliqué ce
que je t'ai expliqué tout à l'heure
j'aimerais lui dire que ce n'est pas en
accumulant une somme de connaissances
scientifiques que l'on a un esprit
scientifique
non ce n'est pas en connaissant par
coeur les équations des lois du
mouvement de l'électromagnétisme de quoi
que ce soit que l'on connaît la méthode
qui a permis de les obtenir
et pire encore de connaître la méthode
qui est la raison pour laquelle on
devrait y avoir confiance en avoir
confiance en ses équations parce que je
les ai apprises dans un livre tu me très
mauvaises raisons de croire quelque
chose
moi je veux croire en quelque chose pour
d'autres raisons que juste c'est écrit
dans un livre
c'est ce que je raconte sans arrêt aux
croyants qui me citent la bible il
faudrait pas que moi le fasse pareil des
gens mais si les et les équations de
l'électromagnétisme sont celles ci parce
qu'à celles dans le cours de feynman ce
serait complètement idiot
donc j'aimerais dire un mois du passé de
se pencher un peu plus sur les termes
qui me faisait un peu rigoler que je
ranger dans la case bullshit genre
métaphysique épistémologie c'était un
truc de littéraire qui ne me concernait
pas je me dirai ça te concerne petit et
ça aujourd'hui
comment est-ce que tu t'en forme
comment est-ce que tu réfléchis quels
sont tes sources d'information par
exemple mes sources d'information à quel
titre sur ce que je fais en vidéo ou de
la vie quotidienne de l'actualité après
tout est bon alors là je veux pas te
faire peur mais ma méthode est assez
drastiques
moi ça fait 20 ans je crois maintenant
que je n'ai pas de télévision du tout la
regarder et ça fait à peu près huit ans
que en plus de ça j'essaye de ne pas
regarder d'actualité du tout ni à la
radio ni même sur internet
et petit à petit je vais de plus en plus
dans ce travers là je ne sais pas si
c'est un avantage ou un travers et
maintenant à chaque fois que je vois
dans mes fils de réseaux sociaux un
article d'actualité qui parle d gilet
jaune ou de la nouvelle loi de loi dans
notre premier ministre
toul des élections à venir c'est un jeu
de ballon prisonnier
je dois sans arrêt qui esquive et éviter
l'inflation éviter l'information ne pas
l'entendre de ne pas l'intégrer et
essayer de ne pas être exposés à ce
genre d'info du présent de court terme
et puis je vais essayer à chaque fois de
remplacer ça une autre sorte
d'information de l'information qu'ils
soient pas de l'actualité qui est là
maintenant aujourd'hui des
préoccupations des autres en ce moment
mais des informations de synthèse du
passé dire qu'aujourd'hui où tout le
monde parle des gilets jaunes où ça
commence à se tasser
c'est seulement maintenant que j'essaye
de faire des recherches pour trouver des
analyses comparées entre le mouvement
des gilet jaune là en dix ans en 2019
avec celui de 2005 par exemple et les
émeutes de banlieues en france pour
comparer les quantités de violence
comparer les deux et comparer la façon
dont les médias ont traité les deux
passent comme ça c'est un travail de
recul
prendre un petit peu de d'altitude
essayez de
faire des moyennes et de - m d'affect
dedans parce que si on s'occupe d'une
vieille affaire qui n'est plus
l'actualité d'aujourd'hui
ben motive moins au niveau affectif
alors ça ça touche - mais mes sens mes
émotions du genre la rage la colère ou
être outragé ou au contraire être
absolument en admiration de quand c'est
un vieux truc qui est plus d'actualité
on peut juste regarder les chiffres et
se faire une opinion en prenant de
l'altitude en des zooms donc l'actualité
cesserait de l'info très très zoomer sur
une toute petite partie de la carte de
la formation et je vais essayer de
remplacer toute cette petite collection
de tout petit zoom très très près de la
carte par une vision un peu plus globale
qui est beaucoup plus difficile à
obtenir
parce que il faut aller la chercher en
esquivant sans arrêt les sujets
d'actualité qui intéresse tout le monde
aujourd'hui pour essayer de trouver les
sites où il y à un journaliste enquête
qui a fait un comparatif au moins un
travail de fond sur un sujet ils sont
c'est plus difficile à trouver que
l'actualité ça ouais ça c'est super
intéressant est ce que lorsque tu as
parce que ça fait huit ans que tu fais
ça à peu près ouais j'ai commencé il ya
huit ans mais petit à petit et je crois
que de façon linéaire chaque année je
suis de plus en plus convaincus que
c'est comme ça que j'ai envie de faire
maintenant est ce que c'était dur de
d'esquiver actualité surtout au début je
pense que c'était pas facile mais aussi
quand même toujours aujourd'hui c'est
très difficile dès qu'il ya un repas de
famille et que n'importe quel tonton ou
cousines éloignées vous dis bah alors
qu'est ce t'en penses de ham et a vu la
dernière 2 et a vu ce qu'a raconté le
président je veux moi chaque fois que je
passe pour un abruti qui dit je sais pas
je ne suis pas un courant et donc bah je
suppose que la plupart de mes proches se
dire que je suis un peu tombé puisque
j'y connais rien et ils ont pas ils ont
pas tant en fait je connais pas trop
leur sujet d'intérêt à eux je sais pas
trop de quoi ça parle ça ça apparaît
avec tivo dans le dernier axe yom
j'étais incapable de nommer le ministre
de je sais même pas quel ministère en
particulier mais parce que était pareil
dans dans une vidéo de du réveillon est
vacant quand je dis ça des amis je passe
vraiment pour pour un abruti qui
craignent rien du tout le monde je
prétends pas que c'est la bonne méthode
à faire et que je la conseille ray aux
autres je ne sais pas si c'est vraiment
un conseil à donner à ses proches de
deux filles - l'actualité parce qu'en
fait moi je sais que c'est tellement dur
non seulement esquivé l'actualité ça bon
ça peut centrer mais trouver de
l'information qui soit vraiment des
zooms et avec du travail de fond et
trouver des journalistes qui ont
vraiment faire de l' enquête de la
synthèse et pas seulement collectionner
des petites anecdotes cliquable en fait
c'est difficile c'est très long et je
pense que je le prix à payer qui est de
devoir s'intéresser au sujet de fond ben
je sais pas si je le remplis totalement
donc du coup je me coupe de complètement
de l'actualité mais la contrepartie que
je me taise promise à moi-même que je
m'étais fixé je suis pas sûr de la
remplir à 100% et je sais pas si je
consacre assez de temps à avoir les
grands problèmes et les vrais problèmes
plutôt prix tout petits problèmes
du coup voilà peut-être que je suis
encore plus biaisée que celui qui
regarde le 20 heures tous les soirs à la
télé mais pas du coup tu ne
conseillerais pas aux gens de moins
s'informer si je vais donner un conseil
qui est alors de hausse il faut toujours
plus s'informer sur toujours plus juste
dans l'aar d'information parce que ce
que maintenant de gudule à moi appelle
les infos en fait c'est c'est le journal
de 20h les infos poigne et donc du coup
c'est l'actualité c'est même pire que ça
c'est surtout les chiens écrasés
aubin au mois d'août il y à des
inondations dans le sud de la france à
ça alors elle est où l'information que
si moi je vais regarder la quantité
d'innovations en france des 100
dernières années
elle tombe tout
la même période c'est la période des
inondations donc un journaliste de
terrain qui viendrait faire un sujet au
20 heures pour parler justement des
inondations dans le sud de la france
justement le mois où depuis trois ans
c'est comme ça depuis 100 ans
l'information elle est inexistante à une
sorte de fausse information
non seulement elle et elle est vide mais
les mains elle a même pas une valeur
nulle faire que elle remplit l'espace
elle occupe le terrain elle dit mula les
informations intéressantes
donc on est on pourrait même lui
accorder une valeur négative juste
preuve fait d'être là et m'occuper et
trois minutes d'antenne
juste pour dire ce à quoi l'information
qui m'épate le plus c'est le journalisme
des portes fermées ce que j'appelle le
journalisme des portes fermées ccc
journalistes qui se tiennent debout avec
un micro et qui disent je suis
actuellement devant le palais de justice
où se tient le procès de monsieur machin
nous n'en savons pas plus pour le moment
mais nous vous tenons informés
alors ça c'est quand même déplacés elle
a pris la voiture le matin quand elle
s'est élevée à elle a pris sa
demi-journée pour aller devant une porte
fermée et parler du fait que la porte
est fermée quoi que j'en sais rien alors
on aura les résultats la semaine
prochaine et c'est un jour ce
journalisme là c'est vraiment un truc
qui me qui me sidère
ouais c'est pour avoir des images après
pour sa décharge voile alors il peut
vouloir y aller et puis inspiré que ça
soit fermé ou ouvert pardon et j'étais
ouvert que fermer et puis bon bah ouais
ce jour là c'est fermé bourhis trouve
que c'est aussi souvent fermé il qui lui
a peut-être pu le prédire mais qu'il
aille sur le terrain aux cases ou non
mais c'est pas toujours au cas où moi
j'habite en montagne tu sais dans les
stations de ski comme des alpes et en
chaque année il y a toujours les mêmes
journalistes avec les mêmes caméras de
journal régional qui viennent interviews
et les gens sur la même terrasse en bas
des pistes pour leur posez toujours les
mêmes questions à il a beaucoup neigé là
semaine dernière vous prenez le soleil
ce que les vacances sont agréables oh
oui il y a beaucoup de neige cette année
et oui c'est évidemment mois de janvier
à tignes il ya toujours des neiges la
formation il peut pas imaginer qu'il y
aura un truc nouveau en 2020 qui avait
pas eu en 2010 9,8 lira en 2020 qui
poussera exactement la même question au
même genre de touristes qui vous
donneront exactement les même genre de
réponse il lui il espère pas qui est un
truc qui se passe
il sait bien qu'il se passera rien c'est
un marronnier qu'il faut courir parce
que c'est comme ça on l'a toujours fait
comme ça
ouais je pense que les gens sont
contents de voir le truc qu'il voit
d'habitude et sans doute quelque chose
de l'ordre de l'habitude
parce que l inverse on pourrait se dire
qu'il ya des sujets qui sont pas des
choses nouvelles comme par exemple le
fait que cette année encore il ya eu
sept cent mille morts à cause de la
malaria par exemple mais qui vont
pouvoir approcher le fait que qu'ils ne
soient pas couverts par ce genre de
médias mettent exactement et tout
l'espace occupé par ses marronniers là
qu'il donne aux gens ce qu'ils ont envie
d'attendre à l'entendre a priori ben ça
dit lui tout le reste
moi un exercice que je donne souvent en
cours ou en formation c'est de demander
aux le jeu un exercice que je donne
souvent mes étudiants ou aux gens en
formation c'est d'essayer d'imaginer
qu'est-ce qui sera marqué dans les
livres d'histoire du futur dans 100 ans
à propos de cette année là aujourd'hui
la en 2010 huit ans on dira quoi de 2018
ce sera marqué les dires d'un plaisir
dans les bons livres a dit ça non mais
même dans le e sous le même nom même
dans les mauvais livres d'histoire ce
que les gens retiendront en fait voilà
plutôt si on faisait un micro trottoir
parmi les gens de 2060 et qu'on leur
dise alors 2018
il s'est passé quoi qu'est ce qui le
retient dhr est ce qu'ils retiendront la
petite phrases piquantes guide par tel
homme politique alors qu'il était un tel
congrès
non est ce qu'ils retiendront tu le fait
qu' il y a eu des incendies en corse au
mois d'août
non non il faut arriver à essayer de
deviner
qu'est ce qu'on retiendra est ce qu'on
retiendra c'est 2018 pour la première
fois de l'humanité l'homme a réussi à
poser un robot satellite sur une comète
qui étaient à l'extérieur dans notre
système solaire
ce sera un truc comme ça d'après tu
regardes ça cette information là elle a
occupé en pourcentage quelle place dans
notre actualité
0e l'alternateur personne n'a parlé ici
avait pas ça dans la une des journaux
car quelqu'un qui ferait de
l'archéologie de journalisme depuis 2000
60 pour essayer de voir quels étaient
les centres d'intérêt des gens de 2018
il trouvera pas du tout cette info
quelque part en page 9 de sciences et
vie et voilà c'est tout quoi et ça c'est
très étonnant dire que les trucs qui
intéresseront les gens du futur et qui
seront du genre à lui marqué dans un
livre d'histoire 2008 deux points ça eh
ben c'est un faux là nous on s'en fiche
on dira peut-être aller 2019
l'humanité a passé le pic de production
de pétrole est en baisse et la fois où
on a tiré du sol le plus de pétrole à
l'année on y en avait de plus en plus
les années précédentes et après dingue
19 s'abaisser peut-être que ce sera un
truc comme ça mais aujourd'hui en 2019
je peux parier que personne parlera de
ce pic la grèce est en effet très
probable donc tu as parlé de pas mal de
fête en fête une serre venir
l'information est très saturé
aujourd'hui elle est saturée par
beaucoup d'informations qui sont ils
sont pas qu'ils seront pas dans les
livres d'histoire comme tu dis c'est
l'heure je pense qu'il ya un autre
problème potentiel avec l'information
c'est que nous avons dans l'actualité et
dans les médias classiques c'est que
elle est extrêmement biaisé qu'est ce
que tu en penses que tu appelles alors a
biaisé par notamment en ce moment je
pense qu'il ya pas mal de guerre
potentiellement idéologique il ya un
raisonnement motivé souvent derrière
fallait immédiat sans clash ne s'en
cache pas tant que ça puisque on sait
que certains journaux sont
officiellement des quasiment
officiellement des journaux à de gauche
ou des journaux de droite et je pense
que ça va être encore pire aux états
unis où les trucs sont vraiment
républicain ou démocrate et je pense que
c'est enfin la consommation de ce genre
d'actualité me semble être un énorme
problème parce que tu en penses
je n'en pense pas grand chose puisque
comme je te le dis je lis pas trop les
journaux je ne m'intéresse pas trop à la
télé et donc ça m'intéresse assez peu et
donc tu je suis probablement la personne
la moins adéquate pour répondre à cette
question c'est parce que d'un côté oui
je pense qu'on en effet vu que j'ai vu
que mon lit pas moi je dis pas non plus
l'actualité et j'essaie d'éviter comme
comme tu le fais et du coup j'ai pas
trop au courant de l'actualité mais par
contre je suis très exposées à des gens
qui qui ont lu l'accréditer bon parce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui la plupart des
gens lisent l'actualité et la manière
dont ils décrivent pas mal de choses au
début me surprend énormément
et puis à un moment je me rends compte
en fait tout le monde utilise ces mêmes
des arguments qui viennent des mêmes des
mêmes journaux qui sont potentiellement
des arguments assez bancale 7 arrive
jamais ça bat sur les sujets qui
m'intéressent en ce moment je ne sais
pas moi par exemple je me suis penché
sur la question des pesticides sont-ils
cancérigènes est ce que le vif aux dates
par exemple en particulier est
suffisamment nocifs pour la santé pour
que l'on l'interdisent
c'est très difficile a discuté de ça
avec des gens en particulier sur les
réseaux sociaux lorsque également 7,7 à
est clivant et que en plus ils ont de
leur côté des mégatonnes de source ou
vent leur hypothèse si le rempotage
c'est que c'est cancérigène
ils peuvent trouver un million de
sources qui prouve que c'est bien le cas
c'est juste que celui qui pense que
c'est pas cancérigènes ou à lui
aussi il ya tellement de sources
maintenant qui peut trouver un autre
million de sources de fiabilité en
peluche tout à fait équivalente qui vont
dans son sens à lui et donc du coup la
démultiplication de l'offre
d'information fait que le cherry picking
la capacité à choisir juste les sources
qui vont dans notre sens et faire bien
attention à faire semblant de ne pas
voir ce qu'ils vont pas dans l'autre
sens maintenant c'est tellement
faciliter la quantité de sites internet
de rapports d'organismes différents qui
font des analyses de leur côté que bah
du coup c'est très difficile de trier le
vrai et le faux sur ce genre de sujets
là c'est pas une histoire de deux
mauvais raisonnement ou de gens qui
seraient qui tirait une fonction une
fonction cérébrale ou une raisonnement
qui serait défectueux soit il peut y
avoir des gens qui raisonnent tout à
fait correctement qui atterrissent à des
conclusions différentes et qui du coup
ces insultes sur les réseaux sociaux
parce que il ils ont l'impression que
l'autre camp est bête ne pas avoir ne
pas avoir les bonnes sources par le
glyphosate mois d'expérience ça un sujet
qui fâche pas que sur les réseaux
sociaux que j'ai eu l'occasion d'avoir
des discussions tout à coup ça s'anime
dès que dès que le sujet des glyphosate
et est abordée et une fin du coup j'ai
aussi entendu
thibault me dire tu me corps ici c'est
faux que en privé y est
vous avez un peu parlé de glyphosate est
apparemment tu semble un peu résignés
par rapport à ces sujets avez vous et
moi il fait partie de je disais à
thibaut qu'il fait partie de la liste
des sujets que je me suis promis de ne
jamais aborder en vidéo avec par exemple
d'autres sujets qui sont tellement
clivant et surtout qui possède les
communautés de hooligans les plus
acharnés les plus extrêmes les plus
virulents les plus hargneux et les plus
méchants ces sujets là je les traite pas
trop parce que moi j'ai envie qu'on
parle pas de l'exemple pédagogique que
j'ai utilisée pour illustrer un aspect
de la pensée critique
moi je me rêve dans les commentaires on
parle de l'aspect de la pensée critique
que j'ai traité dans la vidéo et si
jamais je l'entends comme exemple
pédagogique un sujet tellement clivant
on ne parlera plus que du sujet mais le
sujet cela se passe ce dont je pars mais
moi je prépare lui parle pas de
l'exemple pédagogique que j'ai utilisé
je partage parents d'autres trucs mais
ces sujets là jamais je les aborderai
accepte le 11 septembre
le glyphosate donc c'est là qu'ils
atteignent les intéressait le le
féminisme féminisme a aidé à nice mme en
septembre et glyphosate les hooligans
virulents sont des deux côtés les
l'écart nist extrême complètement 2b
avec des arguments complètement idiot il
y en a et puis des vegan avec des
arguments complètement débile il y en a
aussi en fait ouais
et du coup c'est seulement ces deux
petites communautés là qui s'envoient
défiant longueur de journée qui ne dit
pas grand-chose du reste de la
communauté des gens qui sont un peu plus
rationnel un peu plus polis quoi mais vu
que on entend que la toute petite
minorité des deux camps ça va tellement
la peine de se battre pour ces sujets là
et moi j'ai abandonné et je disais à
thibaut que je me suis résigné sur
l'échec de communication sur le
glyphosate que maintenant c'est acté ça
sent la loi et elle est passée dans cinq
ans ce sera interdite
mon avis c'est pas possible de revenir
en arrière donc du coup dépenser de
l'énergie du temps du fight et puis des
menaces de mort pour pour ça il ya
d'autres combats
il faut que je fasse le tri dans mes
dents mais sujet à traiter ça ça me
paraît beaucoup d'efforts à fournir pour
très peu de chance de résultat
je crois bien que veux tu veux insister
sur la méthode plutôt que sur les
résultats mais ce cas pas comme des
sujets où tu dis il ya bien sûr la
tivement peu d'organismes et et l'a
peut-être qu'il ya moyen de de la dette
a amené un peu plus à une conclusion
plutôt qu'à une autre qui correspondrait
plus à par exemple pressants ces
scientifiques
bah ouais bien sûr que comme quoi tu
vois je n'ai pas mis dans ma liste des
sujets tels chine controversé la
religion d'un et moi j'ai fait plein de
vidéos sur la religion très intelligent
et moi chaque vidéo que j'ai fait sur la
religion plutôt exactement sur
l'épistémologie de l'existence de ces
différentes j'ai organisé mais ces
sujets là tous les commentaires sont
toujours rester poli courtois
il y à des croyants de plein de
religions différentes qui n'étaient pas
d'accord avec mes arguments et qu'ils
ont explicité de façon rationnelle
carrés au lit argumentez et les fils de
commentaires de ces deux vidéos là j'ai
trouvé extraordinaire
je suis très surpris assas et ses
travaux créatifs et citations c'est
impressionnant parce que c'est vraiment
pas facile de parler de ces sujets voilà
de façon vraiment par en parler parce
qu'il ya tu vois cette solution d'être
un peu gentil avec tout le monde mais de
pain juste à tf1 parler du sujet juste
en surface et du coup ça peut plaire à
tout le monde mais toi tu vas quand même
vraiment dans les détails et tu parvient
néanmoins à faire un truc qui qui plaît
à tous ma conclusion c'est que en fait
les communautés de hooligans hardcore et
virulent ben elles sont pas là où on
pense qu'elles sont en fait tout le
monde te citerai comme sujet tabou donc
il ne faudrait pas abordé en société la
religion alors qu en fait moi je pense
que
c'est un sujet qui va aux sites google
ça si ça peut être chaud mais koumaré 11
septembre ou coup d'arrêt au glyphosate
je pense que ses rangs des ordres de
grandeurs très différents moi je préfère
largement mieux discuter de religion
avec ma belle famille que d'aborder le
sujet du glyphosate avec ça que j'ai
aussi eu des expériences paris de région
a été beaucoup plus agréable et très
facile et me rend vraiment agréable
alors que le défaut a été beaucoup plus
difficile c'est culturellement très
dépendant aussi ça c'est en france il ya
des pays dans le monde où les priorités
ne seront pas les mêmes
mais en france en tout cas nous on
parler de religion donc pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas si tocci tout
ça en fait bah ça m'amène à notre pain
ca qu'est ce que tu penses de la
communauté et éthique ou rationaliste en
france je ne sais pas trop quoi te
répondre c'est quoi la communauté et
éthiques
je sais pas j'ai pas envie de définir à
ça de façon très précise mais je pense
qu'il est pas mal de gens qui voient un
petit peu un espèce de enfin pas mal de
youtube hurd de gens sur twitter ou sur
en podcast qui sont assez proches de
celles où j'en vois les communautés
virtuelles les communautés sur
l'internet et sur les réseaux sociaux
adacore donc c'est très différent parce
qu'en fait la communauté des sceptiques
ou des rationalistes dans le monde
francophone
c'est très foisonnant et c'est
passionnant ça se passe dans les
associations
ça se passe dans les laboratoires comme
l'observatoire zététique où on peut
faire des protocoles pour essayer
d'évaluer la reproductibilité d'un
pouvoir paranormal par exemple d'une
thérapie alternative qui nous a l'air
étonnante et ça c'est fascinant et c'est
très convivial
c'est généralement plutôt rigolo c'est
notre credo l'association c'est bière et
éthiques
et les deux ne va pas sans l'autre c'est
quelque chose qui se partagent en
société comme enjeu de société ou
quelque chose comme ça et
et c'est quelque chose de très agréable
en plus cela nous force à avoir une
communication avec l'étonnant des
pseudosciences ou l'étonnant du
paranormal qui puisse aboutir à une
collaboration puisque l'intérêt c'est de
faire un protocole ce qu'il faut c'est
bien sûr que à 2 les praticiens et les
expérimentateurs puissent travailler
ensemble à un projet commun se voir
plusieurs week-ends d'affilée pour
pouvoir avoir un nombre d'échantillons
de patients qui soit suffisamment grand
pour faire des statistiques
c'est du travail à long terme donc on
est obligé d'être courtois polis
conviviale et détendue
ce qui est très différent de la
communauté des sceptiques dont il me
parlait celle sur l'internet en
particulier sur les réseaux sociaux et
sur youtube
là c'est très différentes là il n'y a
plus aucun intérêt à vouloir collaborer
avec l'étonnant et au contraire même vu
que le nombre de vues et le le buzz est
proportionnelle aux côtés clash de la
mise en scène du coup là il ya
exactement les incentives qui sont
inverses et la ba oui nous voilà je suis
souvent très déçu alors avant d'en
revenir à cette communauté internet
est ce que tu peux nous parler parce que
tu parlais de l'observatoire zététique
c'est ça oui et tu disais qu'il y avait
aussi des autres associations pose pas
en france ceux qui suivent à peu près
les mêmes principes que bien sûr
j'essaye de tenir à jour une petite
galaxie des structures sceptiques
francophones sur mon site internet en
cherchant galaxie sceptique dans un
moteur de recherche on la trouve tout de
suite et j'ai fait une petite liste non
exhaustive de toutes les associations
françaises sceptiques ou rationaliste de
tous les projets
les projets de compilation de internet
de vidéos les blogueurs les vidéastes
qui parle des sujets je fais une petite
compilation des oeuvres de littérature
sur le sujet les grands honneurs qui ont
parlé de scepticisme de rationalisme
depuis les grands classiques de
l'antiquité jusqu'aux acteurs jusqu'aux
auteurs contemporains d'aujourd'hui qui
publie beaucoup souvent en psychologie
sociale
et en sociologie et donc voilà oui il ya
plein de plein d'autres associations moi
dans mon monde idéal il y aurait une
association sceptique dans chaque ville
de france ce qui n'est pas encore le cas
c'est bien dommage pour l'instant il ya
combien d'associations et combien de
personnes par l'association à peu près
c'est très peu très très peu ou à
grenoble
je pense que l'observatoire zététique
c'est une des plus grandes associations
en france on est une quarantaine
d'inscrits et une quinzaine de membres
actifs quoi et à d'autres associations
oui bien sûr en belgique il ya le comité
parra qui est très actif
c'est une des plus anciennes
associations sceptiques de rap il y à
des communautés
il ya des associations sceptiques
nationale dans à peu près tous les pays
européens en italie allemagne
moi ce que j'aimerais c'est que il y ait
plein de petites structures pour que ce
soit des activités locales parce que
comme je l ai dit tout à l'heure
plus est centralisé sur l'internet et du
coup complètement dé localiser
géographiquement et moins les gens se
voient et du coup le côté guerre de la
bière et zététique disparaît et je pense
que biarritz a dessiné primordial la
bière confère un protocole ou pour
avancer ou pour faire des conférences ou
pour organiser des actions de terrain à
la fête de la science pour pour faire
pour faire vraiment la pratique de la
zététique il faut que ce soit locale en
fait ça peut pas être une grosse associe
nationale qui chapeaute tour avec
seulement les très motivés et du coup il
ya des associations à paris à lyon oui
bien sûr ben il ya souvent les gens
sceptiques qui se regroupent autour des
manifestations du genre conférences
régulières
donc une fois par mois il ya les
rencontres êtes à paris
et c'est là qu'on peut rencontrer tous
les gens actifs de la communauté
sceptiques parisienne et c'est là que se
situe donc c'est là qu'on trouve tous
les cinéastes et les blogueurs les gens
qui
qui font du protocole aussi ou qui
traite de ces sujets là où qui écrivent
des livres en bretagne par exemple il ya
les sceptiques de l'ouest se fédèrent et
puis s'ils font d'activités aussi qu'ils
sont dans une ville en particulier où
est-ce qu'ils vont tes dans les
différentes îles en bretagne non là
c'est un territoire assez grand et c'est
leur sujet de questionnement en ce
moment c'est de savoir à quel point on
s'est élargi pour accueillir les gens
qui viennent de nantes ou de je ne sais
pas ou pas quoi les plus actives en fait
c'est celle qui sont géographiquement
très petit
le case à nice par exemple le centre
d'analysé et éthiques
c'est dans le berceau historique
francophone de la zététique puisque
c'est là que henry broc donner des cours
de zététique à l'université cette
association là elle n'est composée que
de niçois et c'est l'une des plus
actives en france du coup il y en a une
à montpellier il y en a une à marseille
pas dans toutes les villes par contre
et puis il ya des rencontres ce qui
s'appelle les apéros sceptiques a lyon
aussi
ça c'est assez récent depuis un an et
demi et c'est de place to be pour
pouvoir pratiquer la zététique et pas
seulement en parler parce que sur
internet ou sur youtube on ne la
pratique pas on en parle et moi je
pratique pas de zététique en plus
pendant qu'ils me disent que moi je suis
et éthicien mais en tout cas ils
viennent mentale et mon projet vidéo ça
parle de zététique mais ça ça ne fait
pas nous et éthiques j'en ai fait un
petit peu par exemple dans mon projet de
création de crop circle ou là on a
vraiment fait un expérience m'étaler sur
le terrain ça on a fait en aveugle pour
essayer de mesurer quelque chose donc ça
ça sonnait la tronche en biais par
exemple parle d'eux et éthiques mais la
pratique très peu
ils ont pratiqué quelques fois par
exemple ils ont fait vraiment une vidéo
que je trouve extraordinaire avec une
médium qui faisait un peu tourner les
tables qui est qu'ils manipulaient le
ouija est donc en essayant de monter des
des petites expériences pour essayer de
deviner l'origine du phénomène et la
reproductibilité phénomène ça c'est la
vraie et éthique de terrain voilà mais
ça se fait très peu sur youtube et sur
l'internet
à part ces quelques cas là la plupart du
temps on en parle
mais on ne la pratique pas je sais pas
si je dirais de un prof de chimie qui
les chimistes skis les chimistes
quelque part oui ils mélangent des
produits parce que comme ça devant sa
classe il voit que ça mousse a fait des
trucs mais c'est plus ça à des fins
pédagogiques ce pour montrer
bah c'est pas tellement faire de la
chimie ce qui fait de la chine dans
l'industrie
oui il produit des molécules pour
naissance je sais pas pour faire des
pesticides ou quoi et donc être prof
enseigner la méthode là une discipline
et pratiquer la discipline
ces deux trucs sont un peu différents
quoi donc qu'on appelle la zététique sur
internet ils pratiquent pas là dit il on
parle quoi à la limite un peu il
enseigne mouly la vulgariser mais enfin
origines mental entre comme je la
pratique beaucoup de couture est chez
direct et puis c'est un médiateur
zététique médias voila voila c'est que
ça commence assez de la médiation
chantilly voici déjà une autre question
du coup c'est que du coup ça fait pas
mal de temps fort - d'observateurs
zététique -8 enquêter dedans qu'est ce
que vous avez appris au cours de ces dix
dernières années qu'est ce qu'elle est
qu'est-ce qu'est ce que vous faites
mieux qu'avant ce qui avait trait que
faisait mal et que vous avez arrêté de
fer blanc bien sûr puisque on progresse
toujours on ya toujours plein de trucs à
apprendre par exemple il ya plusieurs
années aux débuts de l'association avant
même que moi je rentre dans
l'association
c'était difficile de trouver des
praticiens et donc dès qu'il y en avait
un qui voulait faire tester son nom on
monte un protocole tout de suite mais
après quelques déconvenues nous avons
maintenant des critères un peu plus
rigoureux donc on a appris sur la la
rigueur pas la rigueur méthodologique
scientifique mais juste rigoureux sur le
côté éthique de telles mesures
par exemple si un praticien sa pratique
je sais pas ce que c'est les sourciers
ils trouvent des de l'eau avec des
baguettes ou avec son conduit les
retrouve des personnes disparues où il
soigne je sais pas quoi ils maladie en
parlera position
les mains en sang des prières si ce
monsieur il c'est son métier que c'est
sa vie que c'est son gagne pain
c'est son revenu c'est comme ça qu'il
subsiste et que c'est un petit peu là la
seule compétence qu'il est enseigné
qu'une réorientation professionnelle
serait difficile à cet âge avancé et
bien sa fierté aussi bien le faire
réfléchir sur le bien fondé de sa
pratique
est-ce que c'est éthique et comment
est-ce qu'il peut gérer l'échec du
protocole bah ça il sait qu'il faut le
réfléchir avant en fait donc pendant les
entretiens a priori avec les praticiens
il faut réfléchir avec le praticien à
comment il va gérer un éventuel échec
pour le laissait envisager les deux
possibilités la possibilité d'un
résultat significatif qui pourrait qu'on
peut rejeter l'hypothèse d'une et que
donc il ya vraiment quelque chose à
chercher deux côtés de cette pratique
mais aussi où l'hypothèse de 2 ha de
rejet de l'hypothèse nul pas d'effet
visible par amant ou d'excès en aveugle
le pouvoir n'existe plus et c'est
difficile de gérer ça et puisque j'ai
appris moi personnellement c'est
exactement le contraire donc envisager
l'échec du praticien d'une pratique que
je trouve un peu rigolote et un peu
cucul
c'est facile en fait je me dirai juste à
je vous l'avais bien dit mais est ce que
je serais capable moi de gérer
l'éventualité d'un test significatif que
vraiment il y a apparemment la cij
applique une méthode frais kantisme la
paix value me dis que je dois rejeter
l'hypothèse nul se dire qu'il faut
vraiment que je me pose des questions
sur la pratique que je l'appelle à
réplication d'autres laboratoires avec
le même praticien ou moins la même
pratique pour en savoir plus est ce que
moi je serais capable de changer d'avis
sur l'urinothérapie et ben c'est pas
facile en fait et il sait aussi une
sorte de développement personnel prendre
sur soi de savoir à quel point est-ce
que je tiens mes propres croyances et
quels seraient les critères qui
pourraient faire que je change d'avis
sur un sujet et où est-ce que
suis tellement ancrée en mouvement
rationalisme borné et qui placent toutes
ces pseudo médecine dans la case du
bullshit
est-ce que ça c'est suffisamment ancrée
en moi pour que je ne changent jamais
d'avis sur ces sujets là maintenant ça
fait réfléchir
alors si vous avez dit alors si vous
utilisez la pédagogie j'amène que ça
c'est déjà arrivé de se laisser au moins
20 fois le truc que du coup l'expérience
confirment l'hypothèse du temps ça vous
est déjà arrivé qu est ce que vous avez
fait si ça mais si jamais en place un
seuil statistique puisse pas moi à 5%
mais ça veut dire que 5 % de nos
protocoles sont significatifs
il ya 5 % de nos protocoles dont on peut
rejeter l'hypothèse nul et ça c'est ces
statistiques ça c'est même dans
l'hypothèse où absolument aucun déjanté
stand à un pouvoir
dans l'hypothèse où personne n'a le
pouvoir 5 % de nos protocoles sont
positifs ça fait réfléchir
ça fait tellement réfléchir que en fait
la communauté des sceptiques sur tous
ceux qui pratiquent un scepticisme sur
les sujets un peu chaud aujourd'hui
paranormal les pseudosciences les
miracles ils sont bien sensibilisés à
cette histoire-là de devoir changer
d'avis plus encore je pense que les
biologistes les chimistes ou les
sociologues et du coup il y a beaucoup
de bail et ziani sme non avoué dans les
proverbes de la génétique dans les
enseignements de la zététique quand
henry broc
il enseignait l'athetic à l'université
je pense qu'il n'a jamais utilisé
vraiment la formule de belles joues ou
ou des mots comme fera semblant mais par
contre tous c'est petit proverbe ou
qu'il utilisait pour sensibiliser à
l'esprit critique
ils sont teintés de cette mesure de
croyance de deux places et un curseur
sur sa croyance un curseur mobile qui
n'est jamais vraiment à 100% ni vraiment
à 0% et à ses étudiants il leur faisait
fabriquer mais mais concrètement avec
des morceaux de cartons une réglette où
on peut monter ou descendre la petite
flèche sur l'échelle de croyances pour
essayer de voir qu'est ce qui pourrait
faire changer d'avis ou à baisser un
petit peu ou beaucoup telle ou telle
croyance que l'on a et ça c'est un
exercice que je pense
te plairait beaucoup et sans même que la
formule de beille ne soit jamais citer
tous ces enseignements de henry broc
transpire de bail et ziani sme et moi je
pense que pendant très longtemps j'ai
essayé de trouver des moyens de
rationaliser nouveau bail et ziani sme
profond qui était au coeur de mon petit
être que je n'oserais pas extérioriser
puisque la méthode qu'on la vit un
secteur d évaluer puis de rejeter des
hypothèses nul et pour concilier ces
deux aspects là de ma personnalité
ben j'utilisais justement ce sont de
petits artifices à base de proverbes et
de curseur de vraisemblance et en fait
c'est quand ben toile et qui on a parlé
d'abord sur sa chaîne et puis dans le
podcast axium avec thibault je pense que
ça ça m'a un peu décomplexée sur ce
sujet là je me suis dit non mais chris a
arrête de faire le le faux cul
christophe samson
regarde toi en face dans la glace tu es
bayésiens c'est pas la peine d'essayer
de le cacher ou de louvoyer avec des
mots de vocabulaire approchant mais pas
exactement ce que l'on utiliserait pour
pouvoir se voiler la face et en fait je
crois que c'est un peu grâce à votre
podcast toile thibault surre actions que
vous avez décomplexée mumbai asia nice
mais c'est de là que j'ai fait les
vidéos sur ce qui sépare les phases de
la lune influence-t-elle le nombre de
naissances et c'est avec une approche
clairement affichée merci bah merci à
toi à ses vidéos savoir un génial juste
donné la citation de dennis linda qui
décrit exactement ce que ta ville
c'était bien de ce dont tu viens de
parler il disait que dans chaque
bayésiens il y à un va et vient qui
lutte pour se libérer
surtout à une époque où le buzz à nice
mettait un peu un peu tabou
la voilà bah tu vois en tranchant et
éthicien il y à une sorte de monsieur
jourdain dubai asian isme il pratique le
bayer sionisme sans savoir ce que c'est
sans même savoir qu'il le pratique est
il en sans connaître le mot mais je vais
revenir à j'imagine que concrètement ça
de vue déjà arrivé qu'un tenant
viennent vous voir que vous fassiez un
protocole et que vous fassiez
l'expérience et puis l'analyse des
résultats et puis l'analyse des
résultats bat à cause de ces
fluctuations de la paix va lui disent
que les étés que le tenant a raison
alors que si on a un curseur de
probabilité on dit que c'est juste une
fluctuation statistique est ce que ça
vous est arrivé et comment vous gérer
cette situation alors voici comment nous
on gère la situation
les affirmations extraordinaire demande
des preuves plus qu'ordinaire si jamais
je fais le test d'une nouvelle molécule
que je veux mettre sur le marché les
gens sont des tests avec des seuils
signification statistique de 5%
mais quand je teste quelque chose de
vraiment extraordinaire trouver les
personnes qui se parent eu avec un
pendule ou les miracles de
l'urinothérapie je pense que c'est une
affirmation qui demandent des preuves un
peu plus que ça car il faut être un peu
plus exigeants et c'est pour ça que nous
on utilise des seuils à 1% et en fait
c'est un petit peu un standard dans la
parapsychologie la parapsychologie c'est
l'étude des phénomènes paranormaux
l'existence du psy télépathie etc et
tous ses champs de recherche la halle
universitaire qui sont tout à fait
sérieux et menée par des chercheurs de
renom ils le font avec des seuils de 1%
c'est un petit peu la norme justement
parce que les affirmations sont
extraordinaires donc nous avec notre
seuil de 1%
nous serons en droit d'attendre des faux
positifs dès que nous aurons fait sans
protocole si on fait plusieurs centaines
de protocoles ont droit grosso modo
plusieurs faux positifs mais nous
n'avons pas encore fait sans protocole
loin de là en fait c'est très difficile
c'est très long et même ces dernières
années on en a vraiment pas fait
beaucoup parce que trouver des
praticiens qui sont prêts à nous suivre
jusqu'au bout du pont ces genres de
protocole c'est difficile à trouver et
donc du coup ben nous on fait on fait
très peu protocole en fait c'est triste
parce que moi j'adorerais en faire plus
mais bon voilà c'est difficile et puis
bon bah c'est pas notre métier nous
et tous on a tous des métiers à côté
tout est bénévole et du mime non je ne
pense pas qu'on ait à se poser encore ce
genre de questions par contre on
l'anticipait on parle beaucoup c'est que
ça va arriver un jour vous fait combien
de protocoles par un idée voilà ces
dernières heures des années il ya des
années on a fait zéro et de temps
l'enfant montferrand deux as et c'est
toujours compliqué à mettre en place ce
genre de choses donc je sais pas si tu
as quelque chose d'autre à rajouter à 6
pts est une autre question par rapport à
ces mouvements sceptiques
comment est-ce que tu les vois évoluer
dans le futur ce qui aura plus de bases
à nice et dans les mouvements est
sceptique l'intérieur dans les
mouvements sceptique je ne sais pas tu
sais il y à des penseurs sceptique
depuis l'aube de l'humanité
déjà pendant l'antiquité il ya des
mouvements de pensée qui sont assez
similaires à ce que je pourrais prêcher
aujourd'hui on n'a pas beaucoup évolué
on a du coup si jamais j'extrapole le
futur en juste en continuant les courbes
du passé globalement ça va être un peu
pareil contre le suivre à 13 optimiste
sur l'avènement d'un nouvel âge
rationnelle ou les hommes politiques
prendrait des décisions en se basant sur
les expertises et non sur les prochaines
élections et la possibilité d'avoir tel
ou tel électorat
ça nous paraît utopique
donc je pense qu'il y aura toujours des
décisions prises de façon irrationnelle
pour suivre le courant des modes des
rumeurs ou des mouvements de pensée qui
passe dans la société puis qui
s'évanouissent l'année d'après et il y
aura toujours aussi un petit noyau de
sceptiques qui essaye de réfléchir plus
sincèrement de façon introspective sur
leurs croyances à eux sur leur façon de
gérer leur curseur de vraisemblance à 2
se réfléchir sur qu'est-ce qu'il les
ferait changer d'avis mieux plutôt que
d'essayer de convaincre les autres si ce
qu on va souhaiter quelque chose à la
communauté sceptique c'est de continuer
dans cette voie là
et de ne pas vouloir convaincre les
autres que être rationnel c'est bien de
vouloir convaincre les autres que que
dure à nos thérapies ça ne marche pas et
qu'il ne faut pas croire toutes ces
âneries plutôt essayer de se concentrer
sur l'aspect développement personnel du
scepticisme
parce que ça apporte beaucoup en tout
cas moi au niveau personnel faire le tri
dans mes croyances et essayer de
chercher une méthode qui soit un peu
rigoureuse pour choisir ce que je me
mets dans le crâne est ce que je vais
mettre à la poubelle ça m'a beaucoup
apporté dans ma vie mais ce que le
mouvement sceptiques ne grossit pas
quand même je perds mais j'ai
l'impression qu'il y en a on en parle
plus qu'avant est-ce qu'il ya plus de
gens par exemple dans les associations
ses tics ou plus d'associations ses tics
aussi peut-être oui mais là prêt court
terme c'est difficile de savoir
je pense que effectivement il ya plus
d'associations que la vente
en tout cas la visibilité sur les
réseaux de l'internet a été démultipliée
ces quelques dernières années
je pense que c'est avec l'essor des
réseaux sociaux
après il ya plein d'autres sujets ou qui
sont démocratisés et qui ont vu leur
visibilité explosé parce que parce que
twitter parce que facebook parce que
youtube etc
je pense que de scepticisme se pose
structurelles c'est juste conjoncturel a
profité de cet essor en particulier sur
youtube moi quand je me suis lancée
c'est parce que je voulais traduire tout
c'est super vidéo sur le scepticisme
dont je me gavais en anglais et que
quand je les montrerai mes amis français
tout le monde me disait je comprends
rien t'as pas un truc en français et que
je ne trouvais rien rien zéro en 2013
personne personne qui parlait de ça et
bah du coup c'est ça un petit peu qui
m'a motivé à moi traiter ces sujets là
parce que je vois bien que c'était un
sujet complètement inédit personne ne
traitait jusqu'à là en tout cas en
français moi je voulais faire judée
traduction je voulais prendre les jeux
vidéo de julia ghallef et les traduire
hextall quoi moi je voulais prendre des
vidéos de ce qu'il y avait à l'époque il
n'y avait pas encore tribhuwan bande
mais il y avait l'équivalent tu vois il
va y avoir 6 veritas y sommes par
exemple la boîte
une de mes idoles je voulais faire aller
ce que fait veritas yom en français
c'était ça mon objectif
en fait ça a beaucoup diverger je fais
des choses très différentes en fait
maintenant mais c'était ça que je
voulais faire au départ elle a du coup
on peut passer à scepticisme sur youtube
qu'est ce que je pense du scepticisme
sur internet de façon générale de façon
générale je sais pas trop quoi répondre
sur internet c'est basket us l internet
je pense que pour reprendre les mots de
gérald bronner un sociologue qui est un
petit peu et étudier la propagation des
rumeurs dans l'espace social en
particulier dans les réseaux c'est
surtout la démultiplication des tuyaux
et la démultiplication de l'offre sur le
marché des idées qui fait que du coup
maintenant tout le monde peut exprimer
son idée et être entendu ben il ya la
possibilité de faire se rencontrer des
gens qui avancent a été très isolés
quelqu'un qui avait une collection tout
à fait inédite fabry collectionne les
petites chouettes en verre par exemple
c'est difficile d'en parler à sa famille
ses amis il est tout seul avec sa
passion et du coup ben à part les fois
où il a réussi à trouver une nouvelle
petite chouette ça va pas plus loin
alors qu'avec les réseaux sociaux
l'internet maintenant en deux clics et
quelques mots clés bien placé il peut
réussir à trouver les quelques personnes
qui ont le même centre d'intérêt que lui
à travers le monde même dans d'autres
pays et ils peuvent s'échanger des trucs
et astuces les bonnes affaires et
s'échanger des doublons et donc même des
communautés qui sont microscopiques
elles peuvent maintenant avoir un site
internet une page un blog une activité
ou une rencontre et faire à une
convention annuelle des fans ce qui est
chouette et du coup voilà je pense que
ce qui a vraiment changé
c'est ça et le scepticisme c'est un
petit peu pareil si jamais il y à une
ronde une activité sur youtube sur les
réseaux sociaux il ya des groupes
sceptiques qui sont très populaires
maintenant le groupe qui s'appelle et
éthique qui l'a 35 mille membres
maintenant je crois c'est juste grâce à
cela je pense
il ya plein de gens qui pratiquaient le
scepticisme sans s'en rendre compte ce
sans apercevoir j'espère que c'est un
état d'esprit il se rendait pas compte
que en fait ça avait un nom qui en fait
il ya une méthodologie qu'il ya un
enseignement derrière qui peut être
disponible et et que pouvoir rencontrer
des gens qui ont à peu près la même
façon de réfléchir que vous ça fait
plaisir et du coup ça ça fédère les
communautés du coup il ya une grande
fédération de la communauté s'implique
sur internet ces dernières années mais
encore une fois je ne sais pas si c'est
très différent de plein d'autres
communautés
ceux qui font du tuning je pense
connaître le même essor ce cas des
choses que tu critiquerai pas ce qui se
passe et des points à améliorer
ah mais aulas la déconne c'est quoi par
exemple je pense que plein de gens que
soit l'étiquette eux mêmes sceptiques
rationaliste soi que je vais pas les
autres voient comme appartenant à ce
groupe là même ils sont réclament leur
est pas on une très mauvaise
communication sur les réseaux et moi
j'ai deux objectifs c'est enfin je le
plains j'ai plein d'objectifs premier
registre ans est venu au moi même et en
fait ce projet devienne rentable
imed parce qu'il me permet de coucher
sur le papier de faire des infographies
et même s'il y avait zéro point sur mes
vidéos je le ferai quand même parce que
personnel j'ai aussi et peut-être
l'espoir que d'autres personnes ça
puisse résonner dans leur tête mais les
faire réfléchir ou moins se faire
fédérer des gens qui pensent pareil
comme je le disais tout à l'heure et
puis j'ai un autre objectif c'est très
différent c'est un augmenter la
connotation positive du scepticisme le
rationalisme ou de la zététique que les
gens trouvent ça cool que les gens
trouvent que c'est c'est la bonne
méthode c'est peut-être difficile c'est
peut-être l'ont pas qu'ils le feront pas
mais même s'il ne faut pas qu'ils
imaginent que c'est ce qu'il faut faire
et que si on avait le temps c'est ce
qu'ont
ouais cette connotation positive c'est
ça que j'essaie de travailler il ya
pleins pleins d'autres celtique dans les
tuyaux de l'internet qui ont pas du tout
cet objectif là ils ont l'objectif de
convaincre les autres que être anti
vaccin c'est nul que la terre est ronde
que l'on septembre et je sais par envie
c'est la mention et en le faisant
en le faisant peut-être avec un peu trop
de hargne
il diminue la connotation positive des
mots et il passe pour les arrogants de
service mais prétentieux les monsieur je
sais tout qui ramène leur science pour
expliquer que eux ils ont raison parce
qu'ils ont des sources alors que vous
vous êtes juste des crédules et à chaque
fois qu'un sceptiques fait ça mon
troisième objectif là sur la connotation
positive du scepticisme
elle en prend un coup et une grande
partie de mon travail c'est pas de
discuter avec d'étonnants avec des
croyants avec des rebouteux ou des
praticiens de médecine alternative et
c'est dommage parce que moi c'est ça qui
m'intéresse
la très grande partie de mon travail
elle consiste à modérée des sceptiques
et c'est moi qui passe par le rabat joie
de services en dix ans mais d'ici là
mais t'as vu comment tu lui a répondu
t'étonne pas qu'il faut que tu aies
arrogant et oui mais son argument il est
fini il est fallacieux
je sais son art du franc est fallacieux
mais ça c'est pas grave comment ça quand
tu peux te dire que c'est pas grave
kristof sas a fait écho à une des vidéos
que je préfère sur ta chaîne qui a de
très loin très peu de vue c'est celle
qui s'appelle arrêtons de partager la
stupidité
un des trucs qui m'énervent le plus chez
la communauté des sceptiques surtout
donc sur les internets en pas tellement
dans les associations
c'est cette propension à aller fouiller
l'internet en particulier twitter pour
aller trouver le truc les plus de 2
billions
l'argument le plus court de la personne
qui a vraiment rien compris et qui étale
son ignorance avec beaucoup d'arrogance
de prendre ce truc là et de leurs
partagés sur sa chaîne
à cent mille abonnés avec un ton un
petit peu méprisant genre mais comment
peut-on croire des âneries pareilles
ballon mais si je voulais faire ça là
mais je pourrais en faire 500 par jour
c'est très facile et en plus ça rapporte
beaucoup d'audience parce que plein de
gens sont tout à fait d'accord avec toi
bah oui mais est-ce qu'il est qu as tu
as bien raison parce qu'on fait un vrai
le personnel souvent vraiment très conne
c'est tellement facile de trouver un
truc idiot sur l'internet trouver un
blog complètement d'un abruti qui aura
un compris qu'ils mélangent tout et qui
connaît rien il y en a plein les blogs
en a plein et youtube et sur twitter il
encore plus plein allez on trouvait est
allé ont déterré un pour le le mettre en
lumière et montrer aux autres à quel
point cette personne est débile c'est
très facile je peux faire ça toute la
matinée moi tu me laisses 4 heures je
peux te faire mais ça me rapporte un
être beaucoup d'audience de crédit de
sympathie des gens des gens qui me
rapportent des laïcs qui viennent
s'abonner à la chaîne parce que
effectivement j'ai bien raison qu'est ce
qu'il était quoi et se retenir de faire
ça c'est très difficile parce que tout
les incentives de l'internet me pousse à
le faire je pourrais je suis sûr
multiplier par dix audiences de ma
chaîne si je commençais à faire ça je du
déblocage
je prends un truc complètement débile
sur les lapins j'ai dit bon voilà je
vais avec des bunkers les idées de ce
monsieur sur l'accent sur le lien
terrestre et un mois je me suis promis
de ne jamais faire d'eux des bonnes cage
sur ma chaîne et je suis très triste que
la communauté sceptiques utiliser des
bonnes cage comme une fin en soi pas
comme tu vois moi une fin un peu
instrumentaliste pour eux pour atteindre
la vraie fin comme un moyen pédagogique
par exemple pour montrer comment est ce
qu'on pourrait faire le tri entre les
vrais il faut quand on a des
informations de ce genre est très
souvent c'est pas tellement l'objectif
c'est juste trouver un truc idiot se
moquer et rama céline et je serai très
triste si les internet et en particulier
youtube continue de aller dans cette
voie tu veux pas faire une vidéo qui des
bonnes que les déblocages
messi mais c'est en préparation mais tu
sais chaque année une petite thématiques
et la toute première année je voulais
m'intéresser aux phénomènes paranormaux
la deuxième année je me suis intéressé
plutôt aux statistiques
la méthodologie la petite ayew est
fréquente east etc
après la troisième année je me suis
intéressé à l'éducation aux médias et à
l'information sur comment prendre du
recul sur les médias etc
l'année dernière mon thème c'était un
petit peu le bayer ziani sme je suis pas
encore vraiment au bout je pensais y
arriver avant la fin décembre
voilà on est déjà au mois de mars et
j'ai encore une ou deux vidéos sur le
sujet à sortir mais mais quand je serai
au bout je vais vraiment me lancer sur
un un des sujets que toi tu veux est en
train d'aborder la communication
sceptique m comment débattre mieux et
surtout comment aborder les sujets du
scepticisme pour optimiser ce troisième
objectif à la connotation positive de la
méthode
mais avant même le fait de convaincre
l'autre finalement un objectif h est
également d'accord avec toi je suis
avoir du mal à te contredire il ya un
autre truc qui me dérange par rapport au
déblocage c'est que c'est ça donne
beaucoup d'importance aux sujets comme
tu le dis et du coup les gens retiennent
juste la conclusion du truc et
s'intéresse pas du coup à la méthode
parfois j'ai l'impression que ça amène
beaucoup à la compartimentalisation
exemple je voulais essayer de montrer
comment faire des graphiques montrant
toutes les utilisations d'une photo dans
les médias à travers les années qui
s'écoulent et j'ai pris comme exemple
pédagogique une photo de deux squelettes
de géant en pseudo archéologie il ya des
photos trafiquées sont contre choc de ce
que l'aide de gens qui sont réutilisés
ça me semblait que c'était un bon sujet
pédagogique et j'étais assez fier on me
montre trouver sujet le gym ça va me
permettre de développer plein de
thématiques sur comment créer une cet
arbre chronologique de réutilisation de
propagation de la rumeur
malheureusement dans les commentaires
tout le monde parle de géant et de la
bible
j'ai en ce n'est pas mon sujet je m'en
fous qui est des géants ou pas dans
notre histoire tellement de ça dont je
parlais et je crois c'est depuis cette
vidéo là qui ont pris 7 août au début de
mon projet ça doit être ma vidéo numéro
3 ou 4 1 je me suis dit ouais bon encore
j'utilise que des très vieux cas où des
trucs qui vraiment ne sont pas polémique
c'est pour ça que je me contente de du
paranormal des sujets de santolino venu
finalement par clive - les gens que des
sujets politiques
mais du coup est ce que t'as pas un peu
peur que c'est intéressant à ces sujets
là les gens apprennent la méthode qui
sont d'accord avec la méthode mais voilà
dès que c'est un sujet chaud
aïe aïe aïe à 7,8 notamment de de david
loi pour qui un moment à parler du fait
que voit le consensus scientifique
il dit que l église aux attentes ou
qu'avec la l'exposition que l'on a au
glyphosate actuellement n'a pas d'effet
cancérogènes en tout cas qu'ils soient
mesurables fois qu'ils soient vraiment
qu'associatif sandales prévalu et puis
si jamais ils avaient en effet et 200 et
très négligeable de devant les effets de
jeu pas la cigarette ou le tabac ou
l'alcool
et puis d'un autre côté ils disaient pas
pareil de consensus scientifique
on l'a aussi sur le changement
climatique d'origine anthropique du
changement climatique et j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya souvent une
compartimentalisation les gens
choisissent un petit peu d'être d'accord
consensus scientifique quand ça les
arrange
et est ce que t'as pas peur quand
concentrant uniquement sur des sujets
qui ne sont pas polarisant finalement
les gens vont se dire oui pour ces
sujets oui ok ça va très bien et
atlantique mais ils vont l'oublier dès
qu'ils vont attaquer des sujets plus
polarisant et bien oui j'ai peur en fait
en vérité c'est ma un sujet fondamental
et qui remue beaucoup de sceptiques en
ce moment même en fait depuis les
attentats de charlie hebdo et puis
bataclan la france entière le
gouvernement les élites et les médias se
sont rendus compte qu'il ya beaucoup de
fausses informations qui circulent c'est
l'avènement des fakes nunit arrivée
trump par derrière et le bras exit donc
toute la communauté journalistique
s'affolent sur les faits avec nous il
faut enseigner l'esprit critique et donc
du coup
dès l'année d'après en 2016 il y avait
l'ordre à tous les enseignants de tous
les niveaux de collège et de lycée pour
enseigner l'esprit critique des brumes
alors les ports sont pas fermées
informés savent pas faire et cette
campagne d'enseignement à la pensée
critique
elle a été initiée avant même que l'on
puisse s'assurer de l'efficacité de la
méthode d'enseignement à la pensée
critique et ça c'est très perturbant en
fait ça viendrait à l'idée de personne
de changer la méthode d'apprentissage de
la lecture en maternelle au primaire de
la méthode globale à la méthode
syllabique sans s'appuyer sur des études
scientifiques solides propres victimes
qui montre que une méthode est plus
efficace que une autre c'est la seule
raison pour laquelle on changerait de
méthodes pédagogiques et là on met en
place quelque chose qui ne repose sur
aucune base solide sur l'efficacité
c'est pourquoi depuis l'année dernière
il ya un projet à nerfs avec un gros
budget national pour essayer d'évaluer
l'efficacité de la pédagogie la pensée
critique sur la pensée critique et moi
je me suis un petit peu incrusté dans le
projet en particulier pour essayé
d'insister pour que le projet d'étude
puisse mesurer la transférabilité des
compétences en parce que en fait j'ai à
peu près aucun doute que ont saigné la
pensée critique sur un sujet en
particulier sur les ovnis banques
augmentent la pensée critique à propos
des ovnis à la fin de l'année si je fais
un test avant un test après que je
mesure ce qu'ils ont reçu le cours
d'enseignement la pensée critique sur ce
sujet là ils auront un meilleur score à
la fin donc je pense que l'enseignement
pensée critique elle pourrait facilement
augmenter la capacité critique des gens
tant qu'on reste dans le sujet qui a été
accueilli en cours moi ce que j'aimerais
étudier cette est ce que les outils
intellectuels qui ont été enseignées sur
un sujet pédagogique aura besoin
est-ce que là personne à la fin de
l'année elle sera capable de les
réutiliser sur sa médecine alternative
préféré sur sa religion
sur son parti politique est en fait
c'est pas sûr du tout si ça se trouve
dans notre cerveau tout est très bien
compartimenter et que tous les outils
intellectuels d' analyse que l'on sait
utiliser dans un des tiroirs on
n'utilise plus du tout dans le tiroir
d'à côté quand il s'agit de politique
ils faisaient tous de notre religion
quoi et du coup je suis assez ennuyé
parce que l'intégralité de mon projet
indigènes mentale repose sur ce postulat
moi j'ai postulé que enseigner les
outils de la pensée critique en
s'appuyant sur des sujets issus du
paranormal
ça aiderait à rendre les gens plus
rationnelle et plus critique sur les
autres sujets qui importe vraiment la
politique et la religion etc
enfin c'est mon postulat c'est mon
objectif quoi et si jamais si j'avais ça
se trouve les résultats de cette étude
là on aura pas les résultats avant
plusieurs années parce que c'est un
projet à très long terme
des milliers des milliers d'élèves
randomisés en deux groupes qui vont être
qu'ils vont être passées au crible de
l'examen critique
et bien si ça se trouve on ne verra que
la transférabilité ou de ces outils là
est très faible en fait sont rois york
ou pas puisque je fais ça sert pas à
grand chose
ça remplit plusieurs autres de deux mais
d'autres objectifs avant de jeter 10 le
développement personnel
c'est un de mes premiers objectifs pour
moi ça va être vraiment faire ces
infographies là ça m'aide mois à mieux
penser ça de toute façon c'est rempli
mes rencontres changer le monde vers un
monde où les décisions politiques sont
prises de façon plus rationnelle jeu si
ça se trouve c'est c'est eh ben c'est
pas très rassurant ce que tu dis mais
bon après il restera que tape des vidéos
qui expliquent très très bien la
méthodologie il faudra aussi sans doute
de vidéo de toi ou potentiellement
d'autres youtuber qui essaie de
travailler un peu plus sur ce set
transférabilité de la méthode à d'autres
sujets
comment gérer un petit peu loup liga
dont nous le raisonnement motivés qui
fait que la tendance à ne pas vouloir
utiliser la méthode quand on a de bonnes
chances de penser des bonnes raisons de
penser que ça va conduire à la
conclusion qu'ils arrangent
je suis très content qu'il y ait
d'autres vidéaste qui traite les sujets
que moi j'avais vaguement ont prévu de
traiter dans la très longue liste de
sujets que je pourrais jamais faire
parce que je n'ai pas le temps et ben
c'est je trouve ça très chouette que y
ait eu une petite cellule de vidéos et
de chênes qui résonnent les unes avec
les autres
la chaîne avec celle de thibault par
exemple ou avec la mienne vous la vienne
avec un jeu pas la tronche en biais et
puis d'autres vidéaste sceptiques que
j'aime bien et à chaque fois que l'un
d'entre vous traite un sujet qui était
dans mon planning de choses à aborder
pour pouvoir enfin aborder un sujet plus
complexe bon ça je peux le rayer je peux
le cocher unihockey barça quand on me
demandera je renverrai versa s'avère
cette vidéo bien fait et le fait que
tout résonne comme ça à peu près en même
temps parce que le succès de la
plateforme youtube arrive et qui tout le
monde arrive en masse up dans le même
wagon
bah du coup voilà ça fait une sorte de
caisse de résonance que je trouve très
chouette c'est très chouette je suis
tout à fait d'accord
une autre question que j'aimerais poser
c'est comment on est tous à peu près
d'accord pour dire que l'esprit critique
c'est important et que c'est important
de mieux diffuser
quelles sont les meilleures façons de
mieux diffuser l'esprit critique d'après
toi en plus des vidéos que nous fait
déjà pas la moindre idée
si si je savais répondre à cette
question bien sûr que ça réglerait
énormément de problèmes qu'on a sur
cette planète depuis des milliers
d'années quoi je ne sais pas trop quoi
te dire en tout cas la solution qui
vient à l'esprit de tout le monde
la première idée intuitive c'est il faut
enseigner ça aux enfants aux petits à
l'école
il faut que notre enseignement enseigne
l'esprit qui dit que moi je suis pas
très sûr que ça s'enseigne de l'esprit
critique comme une compétence une
compétence comme parent peut poser une
division sur un papier avec un crayon
c'est une compétence à acquérir une fois
qu'on sait faire on sait faire l'esprit
critique ce matin en une compétence un
ses hommes c'est une attitude c'est une
position une attitude face au monde
face à un truc que l'on ne comprend pas
et il n'y a pas de compétences qui
permettent d'augmenter cette attitude
faudrait rendre les gens un peu plus
curieux mais quand tu fais ça pour
enseigner la curiosité c'est très
difficile en fait c'est vraiment un truc
qu'on peut vraiment renseigné du pense
ou alors on peut donner envie
d'apprendre et de se former sur ce sujet
là donc là je pense quelque chose à
faire sur ce qu'on a montré que c'est
cool montrer que c'est intéressant
montrer que c'est important
pas forcément enseigner la discipline
elle même et au moins montrer que ça
vaut le coup de s'y intéresser et c'est
pas un truc chiant c'est un truc quoi et
quand je vois que je sais pas moi si sur
twitter je fais afficher tous les tweets
cantonnant le mot et éthiques
mais la très très grande majorité c'est
pour critiquer c'est scientifique
arrogant qui pensent tout savoir et qui
ramène leur science et qui rabaisse les
autres en montrant leur sophisme
du coup tous ces tweets là là il montre
bien que pas du tout en train
d'accomplir ce truc à nous on essaie
d'enseigner des compétences mais si on
enseigne ses compétences sans donné
l'envi de reconnaître plus de demandes
de montrer qu'en fait c'est c'est cool
qu'il a du fun et de la bière et kirsty
love
si on montre pas ça mais ça deviendra
juste un truc intellectuelle aux chiens
ont réservé une petite élite de gens qui
ont fait des études de sciences et qui
viennent se la ramener
et ça ce serait le pire qui puisse
arriver je pense c'est que l'on se
focalise sur la les compétences à
enseigner les moteurs de recherche
croiser les sources soit en perdant
l'objectif de la connotation positive
attribués à la communauté sceptiques ou
au moins la démarche intellectuelle
s'expliquer et j'ai l'impression que le
très grande partie des blogueurs des
vidéastes des auteurs de livres du monde
de scepticisme francophones aujourd'hui
rame à contre courant de cet objectif là
ça fait exactement aequo avec les
mathématiques
je pense que le gros problème en
mathématiques aujourd'hui c'est patent
qu'est ce qu'on enseigne comment on
enseigne c'est vraiment le fait que les
gens ont peur des mathématiques budget
c'est de taper mat sur twitter pour voir
quelles sont les réponses
et ça va pas être très élogieux que
celui qui arrive à convaincre quelqu'un
que c'est cool
même si la personne en question ne s'est
jamais posé une opération une division
sur un papier et un crayon mais le fait
qu'elle trouve que ce serait cool de s'y
intéresser si elle avait le temps déjà
c'est un gros plus je t'avais entendu
utiliser la métaphore de la sécurité
routière dans une de tes vidéos
oui tu es tu expliquer que en gros pour
pouvoir bien non traité l'information il
y avait un peu de façon à ce que tu peux
expliquer la métaphore d'ailleurs mouais
c'est une que j'utilise beaucoup en
formation sur l'éducation aux médias à
propos de comment traiter les fausses
nouvelles les fake nous bref le sujet
trendy à la mode que tous les
journalistes et tous les politiques en
temps il faut lutter contre les technos
au québec comment on fait
et je vais utiliser cette métaphore pour
montrer aux différentes méthodes pour
lutter contre les techniques et une
méthode qui consisterait à à censurer
les fausses nouvelles ou deux trucs faux
ou nuisible car de les couper le site
internet
c'est ce qu'avait fait ma croûte des
premières choses qui l'a fait au début
d'arriver à dans son quinquennat et il
avait fait supprimer des sites internet
qui traitait de l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse
il se présentait comme un des sites
d'informations neutres voulant aider les
personnes qui ont des grossesses non
désirées mais en fait en vrai quand on
envoyait un mail nous convenons
répondait au téléphone les personnes en
face exagéré énormément les risques
encourus pour convaincre de ne pas
aborder pour départ des raisons
religieuses derrière une idéologie
d'idées donc ce site là était qu'on ne
se trompe pas nocif
je suis certain que le monde est mieux
sans ces sites là qu'avec mais est-ce
que les censures et c'est la bonne
méthode
parce que si oui ça veut dire quoi c'est
à dire quand on fait comme ça maintenant
c'est la méthode sarko qu'entre
l'exécutif de notre république trouve
que quelque chose est faut il le coupe
le robinet de l'internet
il fait switch-off hommes
puis ils arrêtent le site est-ce que
c'est comme ça qu'on fait maintenant
larry est ce que c'est bien la règle
j'espère que non ça me fait très peur et
ce serait dans la métaphore routière
comme interdire l'accès à une route que
l'on jugerait trop dangereuse barre la
route ou via les temps et puis comme ça
c'est sûr qu'à pas les clients mais bien
du coup c'est sûr qu'il ya pas d
accidents de la route de les bloquer est
ce qu'il n'ya pas mieux quoi il ya
d'autres méthodes c'est de baliser la
route de mettre des panneaux de
signalisation pour indiquer attention
cette route est dangereuse il y a des
gravats alesi à vos risques et périls
rester vigilant donc la route elle n'est
pas interdite peut y aller quand même
mais on est prévenu massa s'est par
exemple les projets qui se proposent de
de baliser l'internet et de de pouvoir
signaler les sites de confiance
les sites de fausses informations les
sites parodiques comme le faisait
l'application le des codex par exemple
une application installée sur l'année
vite son navigateur qui proposait de
faire lever un drapeau rouge quand on
est en face à un site d information
inconnu bleus quand on est face à un
site parodique le graphique qui raconte
que des trucs faux mais de façon
humoristique et parodique et puis
surtout il avait aussi fait un drapeau
orange qui se lèvent quand le site est
connu pour avoir des infos biaisé par
leur idéologie
hélas beaucoup plus litigieux plus
difficile de faire celui qui décide
quand lever ou pas ce drapeau orange
il est il utilise lui même nom sont
l'idéologie biaisée de son parti
politique à lui et ben du coup c'est
très délicat et moi je proposais une
troisième tome qui est la méthode la
moins efficace
je pense qui est la méthode la plus
longue avec le moment une chance de
succès c'est la méthode de l'éducation
qui a enseigné aux gens comment aborder
les médias avec un peu de recul comment
faire le tri dans les informations et
essayer de le renseigner les raisons
pour lesquelles quelqu'un voudrait
écrire un truc faux sur internet tout le
canton connaît les raisons du pourquoi
ce truc faut hélas dans mon fils twitter
parce que peut-être il renvoie sur une
page d'un article qui a plein de pub
autour et qui donc a des revenus
publicitaires qui sont proportionnelles
au nombre de clics et que donc bat pour
faire du clic il faut du
sensationnalisme que c'est pour ça que
c'est aussi sensationnalisme et qu'il ya
une surenchère et quand on comprend les
mécanismes économiques qu'il ya derrière
je pense qu'on est un petit peu plus
vigilant on a peu immunisés face à ça et
on a un peu plus de recul et enseigner
ça pas uniquement aux petits aux enfants
à l'école comme moi je les montre et sur
machin mais surtout aux vieux aux
retraités ou aux actifs c'est eux qui
partage le plus de fausses nouvelles
lancé par la passe pas les jeunes qui
sont aux collégiens qui partagent ces
genres de désinformation change la
politique le petit chose a touché à
toute la population ben ça me paraît une
bonne idée a augmenté l'éducation aux
médias global de la population me paraît
une bonne façon de faire mais à ducos
ici j'essaie de prendre ça au sérieux et
que j'essaie com comment ils feraient
quoi il y aurait des cours pour adultes
ou comment est ce qu'on pourrait faire
pour éduquer voilà je ne sais pas trop
déjà on va l'enseigné dans les écoles
pour la génération à venir c'est à dire
que eux ils seront au point quand ils
seront actifs et retraités
mais ça c'est dans 40 50 ans c'est assez
pour du très long terme
aujourd'hui tout de suite moi c'est pour
ça que je me suis lancée sur une plate
forme d'éducation populaire et gratuite
sur le dailymotion youtube parce que ça
touche beaucoup de gens et puis c'est un
large spectre de deux classes sociales
de sociologie maintenant il comme
beaucoup de gens qui ont internet
ce n'est pas seulement une petite élite
de nantis et du coup bah on peut toucher
tous les âges
maintenant des gens amaral 12 13 ans ils
ont pu naviguer sur youtube
de façon tout à fait autonome mais c'est
un peu flippant avec un chauffe-eau à
faire face à ce constat là ont du coup
de de 12 13 ans jusque jusqu'au vieux
sur toutes les classes sociales de la
population sur tout le territoire
français
tout le monde a accès à ça c'est ce qui
me paraissait maximiser l'impact de ce
que je peux raconter vraiment moi
j'avais raconté exactement les mêmes
choses que moi je raconte en vidéo sur
le blog de le
14 et éthique pendant de nombreuses
années et parfois notre petite
publication mensuelle que l'on imprimait
que l'on distribuait on pouvait
déboucher le champagne quand on avait
300 vues et quand j' ai dit exactement
les mêmes choses mais dans un format
vidéo voilà tout de suite c'est cent
mille vu et je sais pas d'où viennent
tous ces gens ni pourquoi à ses fins
marche mieux en vidéo quand blog moi
j'aurais été persuadé à avant de voir ça
que non le format et chris un format qui
est plus pertinent pour la pédagogie que
on peut mieux l'idée le lecteur qu'il va
à son rythme et que donc c'est mieux
pour expliquer quelque chose je reste
soutenu que non les cris le blog c'est
mou et je viens me rendre à l'évidence
que je sais pas ce que ton source parce
que tu dois mieux connaître que c'est ça
que moi ça doit être les algorithmes des
plateformes comme youtube barioz qui
arrive à répartir ta vidéo sur un sur
une quantité de gens qui passaient
colossal
je trouve ça très bon match ça aussi que
je m'imagine les gens préfèrent le
format vidéo et son non plus haïti plus
facilement sur une vidéo youtube puis
enfin la vidéo aussi est lancé il ya une
conférence de david au havre où il
parlait de ça pourquoi ce que youtube
est beaucoup plus efficace que le blog
et lui disait que c'est vraiment la fête
de parler à d'avoir le langage parlé qui
est beaucoup plus facile et beaucoup
plus fluide beaucoup plus séduisant de
certaine manière cet article là est
superbe il expliqué même que ça permet à
celui qui explique d'avoir le contrôle
du flux de l'argumentation de commencer
par les prémices dans suite montré
l'argumentation puis la conclusion et
enfin les exceptions et puis modéré le
très beau alors que dans un article on
fera ça en fait si on regarde les images
on regarde les chapeaux si ça nous
intéresse on lit le premier chapitre est
la conclusion si vraiment ça va dans le
sens de ce qu'on en pense et où que ça
nous intéresse
alors on lit les chapitres un petit peu
du coup là le regard du spectateur
faut pas croire qu'il y le premier
caractère du titre puis le sous titre
puis le premier paragraphe dans l'ordre
on lit pas du tout comme ça un article
un article on le livre en zigzag de
façon tout à fait désordonnée et quand
on veut je sois moi suscité une émotion
ça va très bien mais quand on veut
expliquer un arbre
menteur qui est construit avec des
prémices des conclusions et des
argumentations logique qui
s'interpénètrent et qui se posent les
unes les autres ne pas laisser le choix
à l'auditeur de faire son petit marché
et de piocher de façon aléatoire dans
les chapitres en fait c'est mieux il
comprend mieux en fait quand on le
laisse partir
parce que ça peut éviter le tir
hippiques et non pas le tir et picking
de lire la conclusion ensuite de lire la
prémisse ne pas voir le lien entre les
deux parce qu'après tu as regardé la
photo qui après tout est basé sur le
titre et ensuite tu as regardé la
vignette et ont du coup battu suit -
l'argumentaire d'altus seulement le
raisonnement tu te retiens la conclusion
mais l'organisation même du raisonnement
on la retient moins et moi vu que mon
sujet à moi c'est justement pas le
l'exemple que je suis en train de
traiter mais mais l'argumentation et le
raisonnement c'est ça moi ce dont j'ai
envie de parler du coup le format vidéo
me permets de avancer mes éléments un
parent dans l'ordre jusqu'au moment où
je les assemble pour former un nouvel
élément plus gros qui soit cohérente et
une vidéo on la commence au début on
regarde le début puis le milieu puis la
fin on commence pas par la fin puis le
début puis un chapitre voilà le fait
qu'on puisse obliger le spectateur à la
regarder dans leur ordre jusqu'au bout
ça permet de pouvoir faire des
argumentations mieux constat est que ça
pas mal avantage mais du coup a donc si
je te suis et c'est un petit peu mon
raisonnement également mais de qui
semble que si on veut me diffusée au
mieux l'esprit critique aujourd'hui il
va aller les plates formes de vie de
vidéos en ligne ont l'air d'être une
façon beaucoup plus efficace que toutes
les autres approches qui ont été
essayées ce que tu pense qu'il faudrait
plus d' investissement relativement on
sait que les vidéastes scientifique
aujourd'hui ont quand même du mal à
avoir un revenu stable on va dire
surtout enfin encore que alors toi tu
penses que tu commences à peut-être en
sortirez
moi ça va mais quand on a dix mille
abonnés c'est vraiment très très
compliqué est ce que tu penses qu'il
faudrait pas pu s'investir trouver des
moyens de financer notamment ce qui se
fait sur youtube dans s'est dit enfin en
éducation
bon je sais pas moi tu sais j'ai choisi
ce format la vidéo et puis les
plateformes que j'utilise juste part en
dépit en fait parce que je ne sais pas
quoi faire d'autre
donc je sais pas si c'est vraiment les
meilleures façons de faire je peux pas
ta sueur et que ma façon de faire est la
meilleure j'en sais rien et après est ce
qu'il faudrait faire en sorte que les
vidéastes puissent subvenir à leurs
besoins et rendre pérenne leur activité
oui bien sûr ça c'est là la question
cruciale à se poser aujourd'hui surtout
que les monétisation par les publicités
de youtube sont en chute libre
il ya encore quelques jours d'être
aigres aux annonceurs qui ont retiré
leurs publicités de la plateforme
youtube lorsque le modèle économique sur
des revenus proportionnels au clic à
cause de ces à cause de ces pubs la
force qu'il va sur sa faim et donc ça
fait quand même longtemps qu'elle les
vidéastes ont pris conscience de ça et
essayer de trouver d autres moyens pour
pas mettre tous les oeufs dans le même
panier dé financement participatif un
petit peu dette publique parce que même
même les aides publiques
c'est en séparant bien compris le
problème est que c'est vraiment un
problème
le jour où la monétisation c'est un
complètement à zéro il faudrait pas que
l'émulsion créative des vidéastes
surtout sur le côté vulgarisation que je
trouverai notre première pour l'aja
s'éteignent quoi donc c'est ça me parait
de l'argent très bien placé que devait
essayer de l'aider à trouver des modèles
économiques stables pour les vidéastes
par contre je moi je je sais pas ce
qu'il y ait le mieux de faire moi je
fais un petit financement participatif
où je demande à mes spectateurs les plus
engagés de participer un peu au projet
j'ai de la chance d'avoir des gens qui
me suivent et que me soutiennent mais
c'est pas le cas de tout le monde c'est
vraiment quelques petits et élus qui ont
un peu d'audience que oui pour faire
gaffe aux biais de sélection en biais du
survivant notamment de pièces d
attribution l'erreur fondamentale de
l'attribution qui permettrait de dire
que moi si j'ai des centaines de
milliers d'abonnés aujourd'hui
c'est parce que je suis bon de talent
qu'est ce que je fais et de qualité
alors que celui qui fait le même sujet
que moi mais qui n'a que mille abonnés
là c'est qu'il doit être moins bon c'est
soit du tout le cas en fait moi j'ai des
centaines de milliers de données
d'abonnés mais je sais bien que c'est
pas particulièrement grâce à moi mon
mental en quoi je suis arrivé au bon
moment là je quitte audience sais pas
pourquoi j'ai vu des bons partage mais
il faudrait arriver à faire en sorte que
tout le monde puisse trouver un petit
peu et tirer son épingle du jeu le mieux
ce serait vraiment de pas avoir besoin
de revenus pour faire ça c'est à dire
les thésards qui ont du temps libre
devant le camp qui sont en dernière
année qui sont le rush comprendre leurs
thèses généralement ils ont un deux ou
trois ans où ils ont quand même pas mal
de temps libre pour glander sur internet
et faire des vidéos sur des sujets
passionnants qu'ils connaissent pas ce
qu'ils connaissent les chercheurs y
travaillent dans les laboratoires et en
plus ils sont payés pour faire la
recherche donc se pressent pas des
salaires mirobolants mais ça permet de
rendre leur frigo d'avoir un toit ne pas
avoir besoin de rentrées publicitaires
pour faire des vidéos c'est vraiment le
public cible idéale pour faire des
vidéos de vulgarisation scientifique et
dans l'idéal je pense que si chacun
avait un vrai métier pouvait gagner de
l'argent est arrivé à avoir suffisamment
temps libre pour faire des vidéos pour
parler d'un sujet qui connaissent le
faire partager aux gens ça du coup ça
évite d'être dépendant de l'argent mais
je sais bien que ce n'est pas possible
il ya plein de ces vitesses là qui ont
besoin d'avoir deux aces et rentrées
d'argent proportionnellement à leur
travail sur ce projet là et qu'ils
peuvent pas se permettre d'avoir
plusieurs projets moi j'ai de la chance
je peux jouer un autre métier à côté
et si j'ai pas de rémunération une année
parce que mon audience s'étiole ça
m'empêchera pas de continuer moi mais
parce que moi je suis pas dépendant des
revenus de mes vidéos mais c'est pas 4 -
chesnais qui en a plein qui sont
dépendants et si jamais les revenus de
leurs vidéos de leur travail de
vidéastes s'arrêtent ils arrêteront les
vidéos et ça c'est triste mais c'est
quand même un parcours un peu du
combattant pour
pour devenir youtuber faut enfin faut
garder un petit peu d années ce soit un
métier c'est vraiment n'importe qui peut
être youtuber s'il fait ça pendant si je
sais pas il est étudiant pendant qu'il a
des moments où il peut consacrer à ce
projet sans avoir besoin de rentrées
d'argent soit parce que j'ai pas les
nantis les riches il a un héritage que
il a un autre métier à côté qui laisse
du temps on ça n'importe qui peut
vraiment se lancer
par contre youtube heures au sens de
c'est un métier et on gagne de l'argent
mais vraiment liés à notre activité de
vidéastes alors là oui là c'est très
difficile assez c'est vraiment c'est
aléatoire c'est pas possible c'est pas
du tout récompenser la qualité c'est
vraiment leur en donne
celui qui réussira et celui qui ratera
sa rencontre avec le public ça se joue
un peu au des quoi elle c'est vraiment
triste grèce ça joue vraiment beaucoup
de chance et le hasard et c'est pas
facile et puis qu'on fait c'est un peu à
côté du coup je pense qu'il y aura il
peut y avoir plus de quantité et de
qualité avec un peu de financement qui
ferait pas prête pas de mal mais c'est
pas ça prenne très compliqué à la moi
j'ai pas de réponse à te donner un si
j'avais la solution je la partage avec
les docks et il ya il ya d'un côté la
qualité et la quantité des vidéos qui
sont produites par les vidéastes
on va dire plus ou moins esprit critique
après il ya un autre truc c'est
l'exposition qui l'ont que et voient
leur marge est amené bien sûr sur un des
sujets je posais sert à que cette
question a beaucoup des gens que je vais
interviewer mais c'est très bien en tant
que vidéaste que l'algorithme de youtube
il a une influence énorme sur le nombre
de vues que l'on fait est forcément si
on cherche à faire d'éducation on veut
que d'une certaine manière toucher un
public assez large
est ce que tu penses que il faudrait pas
essayé de pousser un petit peu les gens
chez youtube par exemple c'est de
promouvoir un peu plus ses vidéos
éducatives plutôt que des vidéos par
exemple sur le changement sur le dd
vidéo de paranormal ou enfin des vidéos
qui sont beaucoup moins constructive
est-ce qu'il faudra pas que youtube
cherche à faire ça ben oui bah bien sûr
en fait tu m'as convaincu avec ta
dernière série de vidéos sur les
algorithmes pour être tout à fait
honnête chacune de tes série de vidéos
on m'a grandement fait réfléchir et à
chaque fois que tu commences un sujet je
me dis - est bon je me demande pourquoi
il par là dessus je sais pas trop où il
va et stewarts de démocratie par exemple
tu vois encore un sujet politique c'est
dommage moi la politique ça m'intéresse
pas et c'est seulement au bout d'un
moment que j'ai compris que tu voulais
en venir aimé ça m'a vraiment scotché
est pareil dans ces histoires de
intelligence artificielle tu avais fait
un vote sur twitter je n'avais pas voté
pour ça moi je voulais un autre sujet
que tu traites et quand je t'ai vu
partir sur les intelligences
artificielles j'aime webos pas tellement
mon truc mais en fait j'en ai rien à
fiche des robots tu sais les petits
robots japonais là qu'on met dans les
familles qui sont rien qui marche tout
seul mais c'était pas ça n'est pas du
tout mon truc et c'est seulement je sais
pas moi au bout d'un moment où j'ai fini
par comprendre où tu voulais en venir et
à chacun des épisodes
je voyais que tu avais un grand plan que
tu que tu parlais pas juste des
intelligences artificielles pour faire
de la vulgarisation sur le codage il
sait pas quelle langue allemand langage
machine pour coder quoi tu as réussi à
me convaincre
effectivement il y a une
nécessité urgente à s'intéresser à
donner des objectifs aux algorithmes
d'intelligence artificielle j'ai même
pas si c'est le terme que moi je
remplacerais c'est juste les algorithmes
de suggestions de gestion des trucs ou
des machins de notre vie quotidienne
leur régler des des objectifs qui soient
qui correspondent à notre moral nous ça
me paraît urgent parce que pour
l'instant ils sont réglés sur le
maximisation du salaire des actionnaires
c'est lors c'est leur seul objectif qu
il faut qu'ils maximisent ce chiffre-là
quand tu laisses faire le dip learning
pour maximiser ce chiffre là c'est pas
où il va t'emmener ça se trouve ça
correspond à peu près à ce que nous on
trouverait bien donc cool mais si ça se
trouve non lorsque la balle oui tu m'as
convaincu que effectivement mais moi je
connais personne chez youtube donc moi
je ne sais pas comment sensibiliser et
je vois pas du tout où aucun moyen de
les forcer à faire autre chose que
maximiser les bénéfices de leurs
actionnaires
alors là je veux pas aller chez une
entreprise et lui montrer qu'il faut
qu'il fasse autre chose que ça c'est le
principe d'une entreprise maintes
reprises elle est noyauté là dessus son
objectif quoi qu'on fasse cette
maximiser le bénéfice de ses
actionnaires et tu peux très bien dire
oui mais il faudrait être moral en
entreprise n'est pas mère teresa quoi je
vois pas du tout quand on peut faire ça
tu m'as convaincu qu'il faudrait le
faire alors la faisabilité mahler alors
je pense qu'elle faisait à huit est pas
si nuls donc il ya je pense qu'un
mouvement un peu chez chez youtube
depuis youtube edu kohn qui a pour
l'éducation gros qui est qui s'est monté
l'année dernière pour essayer de
promouvoir un peu plus et youtuber
éducatif
je pense que youtube a quand même dans
une situation où ils sont ils ont une
image publique à défendre et youtube
c'est un peu associé à du bon et surtout
du moins bon et du coup qu'ils ont quand
même intérêt à mettre un peu en avant ce
qui est de bon
sur les sur youtube même au niveau
incentive économique je pense que ça
fait partie un peu de leur intérêt même
si c'est clairement pas leur intérêt
principal
après je pense qu une situation assez
intéressante qui fins et intéressantes
qui se passe avec avec youtube google ou
des grosses entreprises comme ça qui est
que en fait elle se retrouve aujourd'hui
dans des situations de monopole qui font
que alors bien sûr maximiser les profits
ça reste une partie importante de leurs
travaux donc je sais pas d'ailleurs
youtube à quel point quelles sont leurs
actionnaires mais j'imagine qu'une
grosse partie des actionnaires du 2 you
tube en fait sont des petits
actionnaires des gens qui ont des
parents bourse les gens comme ça donc
c'est pas non plus un petit groupe de
gens chez youtube qui chez google qui
sont vraiment aux commandes
et si une entreprise est un peu en
situation de monopole comme ça ça fait
que les femmes surtout si les dirigeants
de l'entreprise sont dans une phase qui
se passe bien pour l'entreprise et qui
sont pas sous la menace de perdre leur
emploi ou d'être enfin d'être
questionnée par leur entourage
il semble que là il ya un peu plus la
place pour
pour avoir des réflexions autre que la
maximisation du profit et je pense que
c'est quelque chose que l'on voit de
plus en plus apparaître dans ces
entreprises où il ya il ya par exemple
google fait beaucoup de recherche en
éthique déjà ou en sécurité désir et
kitty publie ça il met ça dans le
domaine public enfin il publia dans des
revues de recharge donc ça me semble pas
tout à fait ça ne semble pas vraiment si
utopique
après tel que je le vois aujourd'hui la
grosse difficulté c'est avoir des
solutions techniques qui soit assez
robuste et qui parce qu'il faut imaginer
que youtube dès que youtube change son
algorithme
on sait très bien que les youtuber vont
vous chercher à exploiter youtube et
trouver les failles de youtube pour que
leurs vidéos soient promus caen ça en
fait youtube et est un environnement
fait extrêmement complexes où youtube
mais les règles du jeu mais les gens
réagissent tout de suite aux règles du
jeu et le comportement des gens peuvent
conduire à ce que youtube se remettent à
promouvoir des vidéos de de terre plate
ou autre je pense que c'est un problème
très difficile et
mais faut plus de recherches pour
essayer de bien j'aime ton
d'enthousiasmé ton optimisme oui mais je
le partage pas moi j'ai l'impression que
youtube il fait vraiment des efforts
dans ce sens l'année c'est parce que en
ce moment là en 2019
les annonceurs n'aime pas voir leurs
publicités à côté de contenus qu'ils
soient non adphone liffe c'est-à-dire
complotistes qui soit sur la guerre sur
l'actualité ou qu'ils soient des trucs
faux voilà vous n'aurez pas avoir notre
publicité à côté d'un truc faux et donc
du coup il ya une pression des
annonceurs pour que youtube fasse le
ménage et fasse taire tous ces trucs là
qu'on aime pas quoi les anti vaccins les
gens qui disent des trucs faux les gens
de la terre plate tout ça on n'en veut
pas et c'est pour ça que youtube faisait
un effort parce que en fait il ya une
sorte de convergence entre leur objectif
principal
augmenter les bénéfices de leurs
actionnaires et cet objectif là les deux
convergent donc c'est cool mais si
jamais ils convergent et pas je peux
t'assurer que des deux ce serait leur
objectif principal qui le suivrait et il
dirait en pub pour tous ces sujets
complotistes nous tout ce qu'on veut
c'est satisfaire nos annonceurs est-ce
que là ça tombe bien les annonceurs
demande plus de régulation moins de
haine - de clash moins de sujets
clivants moins de sujets et ne donc moi
je trouve ça cool d'ailleurs je vais
juste me réjouir de la convergence de
ces deux de ces deux objectifs mais je
veux pas imaginer que si jamais c'est un
jour ces deux objectifs divergent
ce sera la morale qui sera choisi sur le
bénéfice des actionnaires je pense pas
ça c'est assez compliqué mais ça me
paraît nature il ya un autre truc je
pense que il ya il ya un mouvement
altruisme efficace par exemple qui est
qui qui grossit pas mal je pense que
c'est un des mouvements qui peut avoir
un peu
sakic qui grossit qui peut avoir de
l'avenir est en fait y'a pas mal
d'ingénieurs ou d'anciens ingénieurs qui
sont liées au mouvement qui s'intéresse
beaucoup au mouvement y compris dans la
silicon valley peut-être plus encore
dans la silicon valley fin clairement
plus sic on va aller qu'en france où ils
vont être efficace encore besoin de
grossir et ces gens là se retrouvent
dans des positions dans les entreprises
qui qui sont intéressantes et si jamais
si l'entreprise est jamais est dans une
situation où vraiment aller confortable
financièrement et où il n'y a pas de
menace immédiate sur les personnes en
charge entreprises ce qui ce qui vit est
pas complètement dénuée de sens
puisqu'on est dans une situation de
monopole naturel avec les effets de
réseau et tout ça qui font que google
sont largement au dessus de du numéro
deux et que youtube est largement au
dessus du numéro deux dans leurs
domaines respectifs
là il me semble qu'il ya quand même la
place pour que si jamais le qu'il faut
imaginer que si un dirigeant son sont
son but c'est de rester enfin son but en
fait c'est c'est de rester là où il est
clos donc c'est pas tellement
l'entreprise c'est vraiment les
composants de l'entreprise niveau
individuel notamment
aujourd'hui c'est possible que dans
beaucoup d'entreprises bat le fait que
la personne soit promu ouzou la personne
soit garder son job dépendent énormément
des résultats financiers de l'entreprise
met dans une situation de monopole ou
l'argent ne fait qu rentrée en gros ce
qui est vraiment le cas de google en
tout cas il me semble possible qu'il y
ait
d'autres raisons qui font que telle ou
telle personne sera promu où est donc
passée c'est une culture qui me semble
pas complètement dénuée de sens et qui
peut être promue dans son entreprise
après c'est très difficile de savoir
comment promouvoir ce genre de choses
mais je pense qu'il ya pas mal de
réflexion interne d'altruisme efficace
autour de ce genre de questions et ben
j'espère que tu as raison
les ans d'avoir mes bras et je mettrai
pas une non plus une crédence énorme ce
que j'ai à dire
et du coup peut-être que tu vas me
convaincre que ça peut être le cas dans
les cas de monopole drastiques comme
google youtube mais du coup suis en
train de me dire que dans tous les
autres cas tous les autres algorithmes
c'est-à-dire d'oublier les haines
algorithmes du monde - en celui du
monopole euh bah ils ne pourront pas
établir de morale dans leur reer et ben
ça c'est triste c'est que tu es
optimiste mais seulement sur une une des
plateformes par les autres c'est une des
conclusions assez contre intuitive de
de pas mal de gens qui ont réfléchi à la
dynamique désir qu'on l'appelle qui est
le fait qu'en fait quand il ya
concurrence ça sent pas bon parce que le
vainqueur s'il y a un million dit à
peut-être qu'il y aura 900 99000
algorithmes sont quelle on ne pourra
rien faire et où la morale ne pourra
jamais être le guide note c'est triste
c'est super triste
après si c'est youtube qui reste
largement vous dire au contrôle des
vidéos sur internet
les autres entreprises qui font des
vidéos sur internet n'auront pas
beaucoup de vue et du coup ont peu
d'effet alors mon côté libristes
m'oblige à faire la remarque que tout
miser sur l'hégémonie d'un d'une seule
corporation privée c'est pas très
souhaitable pour l'avenir de l'humanité
si on pouvait au contraire des
googleliser l'internet
moi je pense qu'il ya plus à y gagner en
évitant ces genres de monopole
gargantuesque de apple amazon facebook
youtube plutôt qu'à vous à un monopole
juste pour voir peut-être l'espoir de un
jour les idées morales qui soit
réfléchie assez c'est assez a longtemps
était mon raisonnement
il ya beaucoup de choses à gagner à
avoir des systèmes très très libre mais
plus je réfléchis à preuve
d'intelligence artificielle et c'est
vraiment quelque chose que que j'entends
au sida part de d'autres personnes qui
pensent vraiment aux problèmes que
posent en intelligence artificielle
notamment à l'échelle de quelque chose
comme comme youtube ou facebook plus en
gros il ya un petit peu cette idée que
en fait la concurrence et le fait que
beaucoup de lecteurs différents
c'est peut-être quelque chose en fait
qui est plutôt de dangereux et que
paradoxalement en fait pour des
questions de sécurité il vaut peut-être
mieux des monopoles
c'est assez bizarre mais c'est vraiment
tu vas convaincu tellement de fois les
que je me demande que avoir quand
raisonnement vraiment posé sur le
packing en vidéo pour être à nouveau
ils veulent quoi convaincu par tous là
je peux gérer l'imprévu de sur le sujet
pour l'instant mais est typiquement il
ya des gens qui se réjouissent du fait
que par exemple la chine soit un
gouvernement très puissant et en gros il
ya très peu d'entreprises très influente
heures en chine tant sur surtout ce
qu'il ya et internet
et il ya des gens qui voient ça comme
une bonne chose pour la sécurité c'est
vraiment sécurité plus sur le long terme
du du monde après contre balancer ça
bien sûr avec tous les autres problèmes
que ça pose et ben c'est des sujets
fascinants dit ouais c'est les grands
sujets ok bon tout cas merci pour cette
discussion ne vais pas c'est juste aux
deux dernières questions que je me
posais à toutes les personnes que
j'interviewe le premier c'est un peu à
quelques actions les messages clés que
tu aimerais de passer aux gens qui ont
écouté ce podcast
si tu peux récapituler certains points
clés ou qui quel est le truc que tu
aimerais que les gens retiennent de ce
podcast de ce que l'on a dit je pense
que le plus important c'est la liste des
objectifs qu un sceptique militants
devraient poursuivre et montrer à
quelqu'un qu'il a tort ne devrait pas
être très haut dans notre liste
d'objectifs et insisté sur un des
objectifs que moi je place assez haut
s'est amélioré la connotation positive
de la méthode sceptiques même si la
personne ne changent pas d'avis même si
on fait elle n'applique même pas dans sa
vie à elle rien que si on pouvait
arriver à une société où cette méthode
cette façon de penser et les outils
critiques qui l'accompagnent soit vide
soit vue d'une façon positive que ce
soit la chose à faire si on avait le
temps je pense que c'est ça qui
devraient être notre objectif principal
super c'est un super message et je
trouve ça très intéressant
l'autre question que j'aille posez c'est
est ce que tu pourrais faire deux
recommandations de vidéos podcasts
livres ou de personnes à suivre vidéos
podcasts cuivre personnes à suivre celle
que je recommande vraiment je les mets
sur la galaxie sceptiques que j'ai
expliqué tout à l'heure là sur mon site
internet et qu'ils ne pas recommander le
podcast axiome aux us et wakim interview
ce serait rien si c'était pas toi je
pense que ça aurait fait partie de mes
coups de coeur de l'année dernière un
projet vraiment étonnant qu'ils aient
acquis est très inspirant pour moi est
vain sinon bah je vais pas te surprendre
v conseillé quelques ressources
anglophones qui m'inspire mois et que
j'aimerais pouvoir au moins retranscrire
un petit peu de leur message par exemple
il ya une chaîne qui ne produit plus
aujourd'hui mais qui a une petite
collection de vidéos que je trouve
absolument inspirante
c'est celle qui s'appelle évidence
évidence et le deuxième a eu en fait
c'est 1,3 à inverser je te donnerai
l'url et il décrit le parcours de sa des
conversions de comment il est passé de
croyants évangélique très très militant
très actif et très engagé à une sorte de
évident cialiste un peu plus réfléchi et
chacune de ses vidéos décrit son
parcours son mode de pensée les choses
qu'ils vont faire changer d'avis et
c'est une des séries de vidéos de plus
inspirant ce que j'ai vu de ma vie je
pense super avec kit certainement les
podcasts de rationalisme picking de
julia galette à super pas merci beaucoup
encore parce qu'avoir été accepté
d'avoir le rôle du 1er interview des
deux probablement et à tout le monde je
dis aussi vous avez aimé bien fait les
trucs classiques et à la prochaine fois
pour un autre interview et qu'on espère
à la hauteur d'hygiène mentale
merci christophe merci les ça m'a fait
très plaisir à bientôt à bientôt